ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL ALL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LOW MOAN.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I RECENTLY CAME ACROSS A FEW
STATISTICS THE INDICATE HOW
TRULY AMAZING.
IT IS TO BE WHO WE ARE RIGHT
HERE AND LIVING THIS MOMENT NOW.
LET ME SHARE A FEW WITH YOU.
THE ODDS OF AMATEUR GOLFER
HITTING A HOLE IN. ONE ONE IN.
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED THE
ODDS OF BEING HIT BY LIGHTNING.
ONE IN.
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND THE ODDS OF GETTING A
ROYAL FLUSH ON YOUR FIRST FIVE
CARDS. ONE IN TEN MILLION.
THE ODDS OF WINNING THE LOTTERY.
ONE IN A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION.
THE ODDS OF BEING BORN AS YOU.
LIVING NOW.
IN THIS TIME IN PLACE. ONE IN
FOUR HUNDRED TRILLION.
THIS MIND BOGGLING STATISTIC.
FACTORED IN A CONTINUOUS LINEAGE
OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
GENERATIONS OF ANCESTORS.
SURVIVING NATURAL DISASTERS THE
GEOLOGIC TIME.
AND SO MUCH MORE.
IN OTHER WORDS BEING HEARING NOW
JUST AS WE ARE.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US IS A
LIVING MIRACLE.
KNOWING THIS.
HOW CAN WE NOT?
BE A MAYES.
AM PROUD. TO BE UNIQUELY WHO WE
ARE EXACTLY AS WE ARE.
WITH THIS AWARENESS LET'S TRY TO
EMBRACE ONE ANOTHER FOR THE
MIRACLES THAT WE ARE.
EACH DAY WE AWAKEN TO IS LIKE
WINNING THE LOTTERY.
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO REFLECT
ON OUR AMAZING GOOD FORTUNE. TO
SIMPLY BE.
WHO WE ARE?
JUST AS WE ARE.
IN THE HERE AND NOW.
AND I JUST APPRECIATE AND MAKE
THE VERY MOST OF EACH AND EVERY
MIRACULOUS DAY.
NUMBER MENDOZA WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SURVIVE TESTS AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER BOND.
PLEASEPUT YOUR HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGAN I PLEDGE
[inaudible]
WHICH STANDS.
IT IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE THIRTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN THE SALLY MET AT TEN AM
ON WILL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK.
READING CLICK OUT PLAN LUIS
READING THE ROLES CALLED
SOMETHING OR CULTURE MOVED A
QUORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY.
EDUCATE TIME TENNIS SEVEN AM
MISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE
.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TYLER DEEP
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MR BONTA YOUR RECOGNIZE
FOR EMOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GLORIA GIPSON AND POWER
QUE HAN TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS.
ON THE FLOOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HOUNDS GUEST WILL BE
SEATED AT HER DESK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA'S GUESTS WILL BE
IN THE AREA OF THE MEMBER DESKS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE LGBT Q..
PRIDE CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MCCARTY COOPER AND
GRAYSON. TO SPEAK ON EN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR IS
PLEASE REMOVE.
FROM THE FOLLOWING PLEASE REMOVE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM FIFTY SIX
SB SIXTY ATKINS ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
SB ONE FORTY ONE BATES.
ITEM SIXTY THREE SB TWO NINETY
FIVE MCGUIRE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW TO TAKE UP
ITEM TO ACR. NINETY NINE FOR
ADOPTION TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER [inaudible]
I'M.
I MOVED TO WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET RELATED BILLS
FOR THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. TO
TAKE THEM UP FOR THIRD READING
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
SB SEVENTY FIVE SB SEVENTY EIGHT
SB.
SEVENTY NINE SB ONE OF FOUR AND
S. B..
ONE OH SIX MR FLOOR FOR A
PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT ASK FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING MEMBERS
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISTER CHIU
SECONDS.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON THE
RULE SUSPENSION CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MR BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLOORS ASKING FOR NO
VOTE.
MR BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN I..
AND MR FLORA UNKNOWN.
THIS TAKES.
FORTY ON THE ROLE SUSPENSION.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL EYES.
FIFTY DOES EIGHT THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MR BONTA YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SEVEN I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER SB FIVE ONE
EIGHT Y. KOWSKI. TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
FIRST WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US TODAY MS BAUER QUE HAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL THIS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM SO EXCITED TO HAVE
MY NIECE HERE WITH ME TODAY LEN
IS THEM BY OUR WHO IS VISITING
US FROM WISCONSIN.
AND ON HER SUMMER BREAK WANTED
TO COME SEE THE IMPORTANT WORK
THAT WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
PLEASE WELCOME HER THE CHAMBERS.
AND MS BERHARAP YOU HAVE A GUEST
WITH US TODAY YES -- FITTING FOR
THE CELEBRATION OF PRIDE HERE IN
THE CAPITAL I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE AND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER JOE MOSCOW.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH HIM FOR TWO YEARS ON THE
AND CITY CITY COUNCIL OR SERVING
WITH THEM FOR THE TWO YEARS ON
AND CITY CITY COUNCIL AND JUST
LAST WEEK AND FOR ME IT'S FOR
THE FIRST TIME RAISE THE PRIDE.
FLAG IN OUR CITY SO THANK YOU
ARE WELCOME TO MOSCOW THAT'S
GREAT HAVING IN THE CAPITAL.
AND DOCTOR CHEN YOUR GUESTS
ARRIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AUTUMN
REDUCE ASPEL FAMINES THIS IMAGE
CHAMBER.
GREEN AND JASON **** FROM OUR
DISTRICT THIS IS A FIRST FOR TO
SACRAMENTO WITH HER DAUGHTERS
MARANDA AND MADELINE.
AT TRAVEL ALL THE WAY FROM
ORANGE COUNTY VIEW OF THE STATE
WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN US SO YOU
MAY AS A WARM WELCOME TO THE
APPLE FAMILY WELCOME SACRAMENTO
.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
PLEASE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR SPECIAL
CEREMONY.
IN HONOR OF L. G. B. T. Q. PRIDE
MONTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR THIS IS H. R.. FORTY ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING
MR GLORIA ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND QUEER
LGBT Q. PRIDE MONTH.
MR GLORIA YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND GAS
IT GIVES ME TREMENDOUS PRIDE AND
HONOR TO ADVISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LGBT Q. LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO
PRESENT HR FORTY ONE WHICH
DECLARES JUNE TO BE PRIDE MONTH
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EACH YEAR JUNE MARKS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE STONEWALL
UPRISING THEY GAVE BIRTH TO THE
MODERN LGBT Q. CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT INDEED THIS IS OUR
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THAT
RIGHT IN NEW YORK CITY THEY GAVE
SO MANY OF US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE OUT CELLS OUT.
PROUD IN FULL -- IN FULL JOINED
THAT OF OUR RIGHTS.
THERE'S A STATE WITH AS MANY
BLESSINGS AS WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT DIVERSITY IS AMOUNTS
OUR GREATEST BLESSINGS.
TODAY THE LEGISLATORS NATURE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IS
REPRESENTED BY THE LARGEST LGBTQ
CAUCUS IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE COMPRISED OF EIGHT OPENLY
LGBT Q. MEMBERS INCLUDING ONE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER THE FIRST
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
THIS COMMUNITY HAS COME SUCH A
VERY VERY LONG WAY AND WHAT
SEEMS OFTEN LIKE A RELATIVELY
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
IT WAS NOT THAT LONG AGO THE
DEBATES ON THIS FLOOR WITH THE
OUTCOMES WERE NEVER CERTAIN IN
OFTEN WERE NOT POSITIVE.
IN FACT IT WAS JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO WHEN VOTERS A CALIFORNIA
WENT TO THE BALLOT IN PASSED
PROPOSITION EIGHT TO NINE MANY
OF US THE RIGHT TO MARRY.
WHILE THE OUTCOME OF THAT WAS
EVENTUALLY SUCCESSFUL IN LOVE
DID IN FACT WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE STILL CHALLENGES IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND WHILE WE REJOICE IN THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN SUPREME COURT
DECISION TO GRANTED US MARRIAGE
EQUALITY WE KNOW THAT OUR RIGHTS
ARE FAR FROM ONE IN THERE TO IN
TOTALITY.
IN FACT FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT
SUGGEST THAT OUR MOVEMENT HAS
ACCOMPLISHED EVERYTHING IT MUST
ACCOMPLISH THAT IS FAR FROM THE
TRUTH.
IN FACT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO THE
SUPREME COURT RULED IN FAVOR OF
A BAKER WHO REFUSED TO SELL A
CAKE TO A LESBIAN COUPLE SEEKING
TO GET MARRIED.
MEMBERS THE HUMAN RIGHTS
CAMPAIGN HAS REPORTED THAT AT
LEAST TEN TRANSGENDER WOMEN.
HAVE BEEN VIOLENTLY MURDERED IN
OUR NATION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN ALL OF THESE
WOMEN ARE BLACK.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE FOR SO MUCH OF OUR MOVEMENT
THERE CONTINUES TO BE VIOLENCE
AND DISCRIMINATION PARTICULARLY
AGAINST OUR TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND MISTER SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO READ THEIR
NAMES ALLOWED BECAUSE YOU MUST
KNOW THEIR NAMES TO KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THE STREETS.
AND IN THE COMMUNITIES NOT JUST
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
NATION DANA MARTIN.
DOESN'T MEAN WHERE A SHANTI
CAMERON CLEAR LEGADO.
MALAYSIA BOOKER TO ME GO
WASHINGTON PARIS CAMERON.
CHINA OUT LENZI.
CHANEL SCURLOCK INS ALWAYS
SPEARS.
ALL CHANGE GENDER BLACK WOMEN
ALL MURDERED ALL IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS.
THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGES THAT
CONTINUE TO FACE OUR COMMUNITY.
AND I LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS
WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
ON THE LEADING EDGE OF A QUALITY
WHEN IT COMES TO CREATE PEOPLE.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE SOLIDARITY
TO SO MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN
STANDING WITH US IN THIS ONGOING
STRUGGLE.
MEMBERS TODAY WE ARE HONORING
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE
THE PROGRESS IN THE STATE
POSSIBLE.
THERE ADVOCATE EIGHT PEOPLE
WHO'VE CONTINUE TO FIGHT AN
ADVOCATE FOR EQUAL RIGHTS.
THERE LGBT Q. ACTIVISTS ARTISTS
CULINARY EXPERTS ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
BUSINESS LEADERS COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
AND EVEN AN ATHLETE.
THAT'S SURPRISING FOR SOME OF US.
THEY COME FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
AND WE ARE SO VERY PROUD TO HAVE
THEM HERE IN THE CAPITAL TODAY
TO HONOR THEM.
IN MEMBERS ON YOUR DESKS YOU'LL
NOTICE A BAG WITH A LAPEL PIN.
AND A NOTE.
APPEAR VITA BRACELET FOR WHICH
10% OF THE PROCEEDS WILL GO TO
BENEFIT SAN DIEGO'S LGBT PRIDE
CELEBRATION.
MEMBERS I WANT TO END WITH THIS
NOTE. 40% OF HOMELESS YOUTH.
IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ.
AND THIS YEAR THE CAUCUS HAS
PURCHASED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
BACKPACKS.
STARTING TODAY WILL BEGIN
ACCEPTING DONATIONS TO FILL
THESE BACKPACKS WITH THE
ESSENTIAL NEEDS FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE LIVING WITHOUT SHELTER
OFTEN BECAUSE OF WHO THEY ARE?
SO WE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE BECAUSE THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT PRIDE IS.
BUT WE NEVER EVER FORGET THAT
THIS MOVEMENT STARTED IN A VERY
DARK PLACE AFTER YEARS OF
OPPRESSION MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY NO LONGER WILLING TO
TAKE IT STANDING UP SPEAKING OUT
ACTING OUT.
AND AND AS A RESULT AND
DEVELOPING AND ACQUIRING.
MORE RIGHTS MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES MORE EQUALITY.
I STAND HERE TODAY PROUD TO BE
INTRODUCED H. R. FORTY ONE TO
DECLARE PRIDE MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL JOIN ME
IN DOING SO NOT JUST HERE TODAY
WITH YOUR VOTE.
BUT IN YOUR HOME COMMUNITIES
MANY OF THOSE COMMUNITIES WHERE
PEOPLE LIKE ME STILL STRUGGLE TO
BE WHO THEY ARE.
WITH THE KIND OF DIGNITY THAT
THEY DESERVE AS CALIFORNIANS.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE MISTER SPEAKER WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE ASSET THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA MISTER
BONTA S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN A
PROUD CO AUTHOR I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR. FORTY ONE FOR
LGBT Q. PEOPLE COMING OUT IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP AND WE'VE BEEN.
LIVING FREE LEE AND
AUTHENTICALLY.
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE LACK TEEN
ACTS COMMUNITY.
HOW DO WE TAKE HERE WATCHING
NEXT HERITAGE CAN BE TRACED BACK
TO PRE COLUMBIAN TIMES IN MEXICO
THERE'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE HAVE
HAD A LONG HISTORY OF
RECOGNIZING?
MACHE PEOPLE OR YOUNG PEOPLE
ASSIGNED MALE AT BIRTH WHO
EMBRACE IDENTITIES AS FEMALE OR
NON BINARY.
MACHE INDIVIDUALS ARE OFTEN
CELEBRATED AS CORNERSTONES OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
SAME SEX RELATIONS ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED IN THE MAYAN
CIVILIZATION ENCOMPASSING WHAT
WE KNOW TODAY IS PORTIONS OF
MEDICAL.
WHAT A MAILLET BILLY'S HONDURAS
AND EL SALVADOR ESPECIALLY IN
RITUALS AND OTHER CEREMONIES?
TODAY THE LATINO POPULATION
MAKES A THIRTY NINE POINT 3% OF
CALIFORNIANS AND ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
ADVANCING LGBTQ EQUALITY THE
LGBT Q. IN THE WATCHING ACTS
COMMUNITY ST STILL FACE.
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION.
LANGUAGE ACCESS BARRIERS
VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT AND HIV
AND HEALTH INEQUITY.
THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA IS IN RICH
WITH PASSIONATE AND DEDICATED
INDIVIDUALS THAT PROVIDE
REGIONAL SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE BROWN BOY PROJECT IN EAST
BAY.
AND TO REVOLUTION IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WERE ESTABLISHED TO
PROMOTE EQUALITY IN ACCESS FOR
PEOPLE WHO SEEK SUPPORT AND LOVE
AND ACCEPTANCE.
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN THE
LGBT Q. AND THE WATCHING NEXT
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO BE A
VITAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY AND IDENTITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY ON H. R..
FORTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
MANTAS.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HR FORTY ONE
IN CELEBRATION OF PRIDE MONTH.
THIS YEAR'S PRIDE CELEBRATION
MARKS THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
STONEWALL RIOTS.
HOWEVER THREE YEARS BEFORE
STONEWALL THIS MOVEMENT WAS
ALREADY TAKING SHAPE IN PART
BECAUSE OF AN API TRANS GENDER
ACTIVISTS.
IN THE TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD
OF MY DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SIMILAR TO STONE WALL.
TAMERA CHING WAS INVOLVED IN A
REVOLT AGAINST POLICE HARASSMENT.
WHEN POLICE ATTEMPTED TO REMOVE
HER AND OTHERS FROM A LOCAL
RESTAURANT?
COMPTON'S CAFETERIA CHAOS
ERUPTED.
THIS EVENT RESULTED IN
ESTABLISHING TRANSGENDER
ADVOCACY PROGRAMS WITHIN SAN
FRANCISCO'S POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND BEYOND.
ANOTHER PIVOTAL MOMENT FOR LGBT
Q. HISTORY ALSO INVOLVED AN
ASIAN AMERICAN ACTIVISTS.
WHILE SERVING IN THE US ARMY
LIEUTENANT DAN CHOI CAME OUT ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION WHEN
CHALLENGING.
DON'T ASK DON'T TELL.
HIS ACTIVISM RESULTED IN THE
REPEAL OF THIS DISCRIMINATORY
POLICY.
JUST REMEMBER THE ACTIONS OF DAN.
AND TAMERA AND COUNTLESS OTHER
BRAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
FOUGHT FOR QUALITY AND JUSTICE
BY SUPPORTING HR FORTY ONE TO
CELEBRATE OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR FORTY ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE
CELEBRATE THIS MONTH CALL PRIDE.
THE STORY OF LGBT AMERICANS HAS
BEEN ONE OF MARGINALIZATION
DISCRIMINATION AND THE STRUGGLE
FOR LIBERTY AND EQUALITY.
AFRICAN AMERICANS RECOGNIZE
THOSE STRUGGLES IN THOSE VOICES
THAT ARE TOO OFTEN NEGLECTED
FROM HISTORY.
THE BLACK LGBT MEMBER HAS BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY LONG
BEFORE STONE WALL.
AND YET THEY WERE PRESIDENT
STONE WALL MARCIA JOHNSON WAS A
TRANSGENDER RIGHTS ACTIVIST WAS
ONE OF THE PROMINENT FIGURES.
OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
STONEWALL RIOT FIFTY YEARS AGO.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
RIGHTS AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
SECURE THEM.
WE HAVE A TENDENCY TO TALK ABOUT
THE FAMOUS PEOPLE WE TALK ABOUT
AUDRE LORDE AND JAMES BALDWIN
AND BAYARD RUSTIN AND BARBARA
SMITH AND PHIL WILSON.
ALL OF THOS IN THE FOREFRONT OF
THE STRUGGLE.
BUT SOMETIMES WE FORGET THOSE
WERE NOT THE ACTIVISTS IN TERMS
OF THE FOREFRONT BUT THOSE WHO
JUST EVERY DAY LGBT PEOPLE
TRYING TO LIVE THEIR LIVES.
TRYING TO BASICALLY BE HAPPY IN
WHO THEY ARE.
I'VE HAD A NUMBER OF L. G. B. T.
MEMBERS WHO WERE MY STUDENTS AND
MY COLLEAGUES.
AND WATCH THEM STRUGGLED NOT
ONLY ON BEING JUST L. G. B. T..
BUT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THEY FIT IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
IN THE BLACK CHURCHES IN THE
BLACK SOCIAL ORGANIZATIONS.
AND OFTENTIMES THEY SUFFER A
DOUBLE IF NOT A TRIPLE WHAMMY
EVERY NOW AND THEN IF THEY'RE
FEMALE IF THEY'RE BLACK AND
THEIR L. G. B. T..
IT BECOMES DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND TO BE A PART OF A
COMMUNITY.
I'VE SEEN SO MANY OF MY FRIENDS
WHO ARE REALLY TORN BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T COME OUT OR THEY DON'T
FEEL THEY CAN OR IF THEY DO COME
OUT.
THEY FEEL THEY WILL LOSE THE
LOVE AND RESPECT.
OF THE FOLKS WHO CARE ABOUT THEM.
ONE OF THE MOST TRAGIC
EXPERIENCES I HAD WAS WHEN I
LOST ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES A VERY
GOOD FRIEND DR DANI SCARBOROUGH.
WAS A DANCER AT SAN DIEGO STATE
ONE OF MY FACULTY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES SOMEONE THAT I LOVE
DEARLY THAT MY CHILDREN
CONSIDERED THE GODFATHER.
AND THEY LOVED HIM DEARLY AND HE
WAS A HE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
VICTIMS OF AIDS.
IT WAS INTERESTING BECAUSE EVEN
DESPITE ALL OF THE CARE THAT WE
HAVE FOR HIM.
HE WAS SO AFRAID THAT SOMEONE
WOULD KNOW THAT HE WAS GAY.
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE WE ALL KNEW HE WAS GAY.
AND IT WAS KIND OF A LARRY IS
WHEN HE CAME OUT AND SAID YOU
KNOW I HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
LIFESTYLE.
AND I SAID YOU MEAN YOU STRAIGHT
OUT WE WAS JUST SHOCKED BECAUSE
WE ALL KNEW HE WAS GAY.
BUT THE FEAR THAT HE WOULD THAT
WE WOULD REJECT HIM.
EVEN AT THIS DIFFICULT TIME WAS
UNEMPLOYED JUST AMAZING TO ALL
OF US ALL OF HIS STUDENTS IN THE
COLLEAGUES IN WHO LOVED HIM SO
DEARLY.
AND THE FEAR THAT WE WOULD
REJECT HIM IF WE KNEW HE WAS GAY
AND YET EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM
SAYS I'M TRULY GAY I AM
WONDERFUL AND EVERYONE LOVED
IMPORT.
SO I OFTEN THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
WE MISS AS A COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WE OFTENTIMES DON'T LET
PEOPLE BASICALLY RELAX AND TO BE
THEMSELVES AND BE ACCEPTED.
AN ETHNIC COMMUNITIES HAVE
DIFFICULTY DEALING WITH THE LGBT
COMMUNITY WOULD WE DON'T WE
DON'T WE US ALMOST AS IFTO SAY.
I WON'T ASK AND YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TELL AND WE'LL ALL BE OKAY.
AND YET WE ALL AREN'T OKAY.
SO IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS THAT THE
THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SUFFER
SO SEVERELY.
IT WOULD HAS TALKED ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR POPULATION BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T FIT IN WITH --
THE WHAT THE LGBT COMMUNITY
THAT'S PREDOMINANTLY WHITE THEY
DON'T FIT AND CULTURALLY THAT'LL
FIT IN IN MANY WAYS AND SO
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO FIND THEIR
OWN IDENTITY.
AND SOMETIMES OWN COMMUNITY
DEMANDS THAT THEY NOT BE FULL
EXPRESSIVE OF WHO THEY ARE.
IT IS INTERESTING TO ME THAT THE
BLACK LG P. L. G. B. T.
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO SUFFER.
THE SEVEREST FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION IN TERMS OF IT
YOU JUST HEARD THE ONLY SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS KILL THIS YEAR WHO
TRANS GENDER ALL BLACK WOMEN.
UNBELIEVABLE THAT THAT EXIST AND
YET IT IS NOT THE FANFARE AND IS
NOT WHAT WE HEAR ABOUT PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY FALL INTO THE
CATEGORY OF THINGS THAT DON'T
UPSET US A LOT.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THOSE WHO
ARE STILL SUFFERING WITH WITH
AIDS AND NOT GETTING THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED?
IT IS THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY I REMEMBER VERY
CLEARLY WHEN ONE OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES A FEW
YEARS AGO WAS ASK ABOUT.
BUT AIDS IN BLACK COMMUNITIES HE
BEGAN TO TALK ABOUT AFRICA AND
SOMEONE SAYS NO NO NO I'M
TALKING ABOUT WASHINGTON DC I'M
TALKING ABOUT NEW YORK I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
HIGH NUMBERS OF ALL OF THE NEW
INCIDENTS ARE BASICALLY IN BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE ISSUES ARE ISSUES FOR ALL
OF US.
THAT WE NEED TO PARTICIPATE IN
SO I STAND TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS THAT HAS BEGUN TO ISSUE
WOULD DEAL WITH ISSUES OF HIV IN
BLACK COMMUNITIES IN OTHER
PLACES. TO SAY THAT IT IS TIME
NOW THAT WE AS A COMMUNITY STEP
UP AND RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT ALL
OF OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS ALL
OF THOSE WERE PART OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AND THAT INCLUDES
THOSE OF COLOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I ASK
THAT YOU STRONGLY SUPPORT HR
FORTY ONE THAT HERE TODAY BUT
YOU ALSO GIVE SPACE FOR OUR
FOLKS TO BE PROUD OF WHO THEY
ARE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT PRIDE MONTH
IS ALL ABOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MR
GABRIEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR.
FORTY ONE WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS BODY AND FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
THE JEWISH CAUCUSES PLEASED TO
JOIN WITH CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
FAITHS AND BACKGROUNDS AND
CELEBRATING PRIDE MONTH WHICH IS
A SPECIAL OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THE
REMARKABLE CULTURE.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBT Q.
CALIFORNIANS.
PRIDE MONTH IS ALSO SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBT Q. JEWS
WHO ARE CENTRAL TO THE FABRIC OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE JEWISH
COMMUNITY.
THEY HELP TO LEAD SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITY'S MOST IMPORTANT
INSTITUTIONS THEY PROVIDE
SPIRITUAL GUIDANCE AS RABBIS IN
KANTOR'S.
AND THEY OFTEN SERVICE OUR
COMMUNITIES CONSCIENCE
CONSTANTLY REMINDING US OF OUR
OBLIGATION TO PURSUE JUSTICE TO
UPLIFT THE POOR AND THE
VULNERABLE TO TREAT EVERY HUMAN
BEING WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
AND TO REPAIR ARE VERY BROKEN
WORLD.
WE ALSO TAKE SPECIAL PRIDE IN
THE MANY CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBT
Q. JEWS HAVE MADE TO OUR STATE
AND NATION.
IN SO MANY FIELDS INCLUDING ART
LITERATURE SCIENCE BUSINESS
ENTERTAINMENT AND MEDIA.
WE APPLAUD THOSE JEWS WHO HAVE
HELPED TO LEAD THE FIGHT FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE THROUGH PUBLIC
SERVICE INCLUDING FORMER
CONGRESSMAN BARNEY FRANK
COLORADO GOVERNOR CHAIRED PAULUS.
BARBARA KASPAR SILVERSTEIN THE
FIRST OPENLY TRANSGENDER MEMBER
OF THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE AND OUR OWN SENATOR
SCOTT WIENER CHAIR OF THE LGBT
Q. CAUCUS AND OF COURSE HARVEY
MILK.
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY PERSON TO
BE ELECTED TO PUBLIC OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS MONTH SYNAGOGUES ACROSS THE
STATE WILL CELEBRATE PRIDE MONTH
WHAT BY HONORING THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AT FRIDAY NIGHT
SERVICES.
WE WILL CELEBRATE ALONGSIDE OUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
AND WE WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH
THEM TO ADVANCE JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY FOR LGBT Q. COMMUNITIES
AND FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR.
FORTY ONE THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MR GLORIA YOU MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST
VERY BRIEFLY I EXTEND MY
APPRECIATION TO OUR FELLOW
CAUCUS -- IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
STANDING IN RISE IN SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF PRIDE MONTH YOU KNOW
WE HAVE NOT COME THIS FAR.
AS LGBT Q. PEOPLE BY OURSELVES.
WE WOULD NOT BE HERE IF IT
WEREN'T FOR STRAIGHT ALLIES IF
YOU WERE HERE FOR OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN ALLIES ARE ASIAN
AMERICAN ALLIES LATINO ALLIES
ARE JEWISH.
ALLIES EVERYONE COMING TOGETHER
TO WRITE THE HISTORIC WRONGS AND
I WANTED ON BEHALF OF THE
CAUCUSES VICE CHAIR THE CAUCUS
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT THE LGBT Q.
CAUCUS WILL STAND WITH YOUR
CAUCUSES. TO RIGHT THE WRONGS IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
TOGETHER THAT'S HOW WE KEEP
CALIFORNIA AT THE LEADING EDGE
OF A QUALITY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MEMBERS AYE
VOTES AND I ASKED THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA RESERVOIR
IS ACID AT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE RIGHT.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON H. R..
FORTY ONE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY NINE
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. FOR THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND QUEER
PRIDE MONTH.
WE WILL RECOGNIZE A NUMBER OF
DISTINGUISHED HONOREES.
I AM APPOINTING AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE TO BRING OUR SPECIAL
GAS ON TO THE FLOOR FOR THIS
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS SHOULD RETIRE TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AS I CALL
YOUR NAME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SURVIVE TESTS.
EGGMAN.
GLORIA.
AND LOW.
IN OUR SPECIAL GAS SENATORS
ATKINS.
GALGIANI [inaudible]
AND WIENER.
I ALSO ASKED ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON ASSEMBLY
REPUBLICAN LEADER MARIE WALDRON.
OUR SPECIAL GAS FROM THE SENATE.
THE LGBT Q. CAUCUS CHAIR SENATOR
SCOTT WIENER AND SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS.
TO JOIN IN THE CENTER AISLE TO
RECEIVE OUR HONOREES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO THE
INTRODUCTIONS OF THE L. G. B. T.
Q. PRIDE MONTH HONOREES.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN AND THE
CLERK WILL READ.
HONOREE ARE YES I EAT IS
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA AND SENATOR WIENER.
MISS ARIAS SEAT IS A CO FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S COMPTON'S TRANS
GENDER CULTURAL DISTRICT.
THE DISTRICT IS A HUB OF SOCIAL
CULTURAL ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
FOR TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING COMMUNITIES.
IN ADDITION THE DISTRICT AIMS TO
PREVENT THE DISPLACEMENT OF
TRANSGENDER RESIDENCE ADDRESS
HOUSING DEBILITY AND EMPLOYMENT
DISPARITIES OF TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MORE.
MISS EIGHT IS ALSO THE FOUNDER
OF QUEEN CULTURE INITIATIVE AND
EMPOWERMENT PROJECT FOR BLACK
TRANSGENDER WOMEN.
PREVIOUSLY SHE SERVED AS THE
LGBT POLICY ADVISER FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMISSION AND AS DIRECTOR POP
PROGRAMS A POLICY AT SAINT JAMES
INFIRMARY.
SHE HAS RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS
AND RECOGNITION FOR HER WORK
WELCOME IS REAC
.
I'M SORRY TO THE THOMAS IS
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER GLORIA.
THIS TO THE THOMASES PERFORMER
ADVICE COLUMNIST.
AND CONSULTANT TWENTY YEARS AGO
TO THE OPEN LIPS RESTAURANTS OF
THE CLUB IN SAN DIEGO.
MISS THOMAS CENTER COLLEAGUES
THAT SORT OF LAUGHTER AND
CELEBRATION TO OVER ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE EACH WEEK SHE'S WON
AWARDS FOR IMPERSONATIONS OF
SHARE AT LENA HORNE BILLIE
HOLIDAY J. LO JOHN JET LI SHE
KEYS PAT BENATAR IN ANY WHITE
HOUSE. TO THE ORIGINAL CHARACTER
SISTER NONE OF THE ABOVE HAS
MADE LIVE SUNDAY GOSPEL BRUNCH
FOR THE TOP BRANCHES IN SAN
DIEGO.
MISS THOMASES FOR PRESIDENT OF
THE EL CAJON BOULEVARD BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT ASSOCIATION WHICH
SERVICE ONE THOUSAND BUSINESSES
AND SAN DIEGO'S MATT CITY
WELCOME IS TO THE THOMAS
.
HONOREE KEVIN'S HOLDEN IS
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
AND SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
ATKINS MISTER KEVIN TOLD AND
CURRENTLY SERVES AS VICE
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN WATER WHERE HIS BEFORE
LEGAL FOODS COMMUNITY AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSERVATION KEVIN IS ALSO WELL
KNOWN FOR HIS WORK ON BEHALF OF
LGBT Q. CANDIDATES THE NUMBER IS
FAR TOO NUMEROUS TO MENTION.
HE'S UP TO MEANT HE HELPED
ESTABLISH A LARGER DYNAMIC CADRE
OF LGBT Q. ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO
PART OF SAN DIEGO LEADERSHIP AT
ALMOST EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT.
MR CHILDREN HAS ALSO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY OF THE SAN DIEGO LGBT
CENTER BOARD THE CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES DIVERSITY COUNCIL THE
NATIONAL GAY AND LESBIAN VICTORY
FUND.
AND MANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS MR
CHILDREN HOLDS DEGREES FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON AT
PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY WELCOME
MISTER KEVIN TELL THEN.
HENRI GABRIEL MALDONADO IS
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
CERVANTES MR GABER MALDONADO IS
THE FOUNDER AND C. E. O. OF TRUE
EVOLUTION.
CHU IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION SERVING
RIVERSIDE AND SAN BENITO COUNTY
ON ISSUES IMPACTING COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR.
AS AN AFTER LATINO GAY MAN
GABRIEL'S MISSION IS TO ADVANCE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE AND HUMAN
DIGNITY OF LGBTQ PEOPLE.
HE HAS SERVED ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL ADVISORY COUNCIL ON
HIV ON SEVERAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND ON THE FIVE
REPORTS FOR THE THE HEALTHCARE
MARKET COMPANY.
AND AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
WELCOME MR GABRIEL MALDONADO.
OUR NEXT HONOREE AS THE LATE
SALLY MILLER SHE IS REPRESENTED
BY MISTER DOLE REINA.
HE'S ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EIGHT MEN AND SENATOR GALGIANI.
THE LATE SALLY MILLER JOINED THE
FACULTY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF THE
PACIFIC IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AS THE FIRST FEMALE TENURED
PROFESSOR IN THE SOCIAL SCIENCES
AND ONE OF THE FIRST LESBIAN
PROFESSORS.
SHE PUBLISHED WORKS ON WOMEN'S
HISTORY IMMIGRANTS FEMINISM AND
SOCIALISM YOU'LL PLEASE WOMAN IN
THE WEST COLLECTION WAS BUILT
UPON SALLY'S WORK SHE IS
RECOGNIZED BY FELLOW HISTORIANS
AND WAS FREQUENTLY INVITED TO
UNIVERSITIES ABROAD.
SEVERAL TIMES AS A FULBRIGHT
SCHOLAR.
SALLY PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY NINETEEN AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY ONE WELCOME
MISTER DOLE RIGHT NOT
REPRESENTING PROFESSOR SALLY
MILLER
.
HONOREE RICHARD POPPIN IS
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO RICHARD
POP AND BECAME A NOTARY PUBLIC
TO HELP SAME SEX COUPLES
REGISTER AS DOMESTIC PARTNERS
WELL HELPING OTHERS RICHARD WAS
AT RISK OF SEPARATION FROM HIS
PARTNER ERIC.
SINCE THEY WERE LEGAL STRANGERS
IN THE EYES OF FEDERAL LAW.
THE WORD TRANS NATIONAL AMERICAN
TAIWANESE COUPLE POPPING
CAMPAIGN FOR THE PERMANENT
PARTNERS IMMIGRATION ACT.
IN THE INTERIM HE ALSO WORKED ON
THE NO ON PROPOSITION EIGHT
CAMPAIGN.
DETERMINED TO WORK TO WRITE THIS
IN OTHER INJUSTICES WE GAVE
PEOPLE RICH TRYING TO CALL THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY AREA
MUNICIPAL ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
REGION ERIC MARRIED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT CONTINUES TO HIS
UPPER STYLE.
THEY ALSO TRAVEL TO TAIWAN TO
HELP LOBBY FOR MARRIAGE EQUALITY
THERE.
MR POPPING HAS DEGREES FROM
POLITICAL IT AND STANFORD
UNIVERSITY BOTH IN MATHEMATICS
HIS WORKS IN APPLIED MATHEMATICS
AND SILICON VALLEY FOR FORTY
YEARS AND HOLD TWENTY FIVE U. S.
PATENTS WELCOME MR RICHER POPPIN.
HONOREE JASON COLLINS IS
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CERVANTES MR JASON COLLINS HAD A
THIRTEEN YEAR CAREER WITH THE
NATIONAL BASKETBALL ASSOCIATION.
HE WAS THE EIGHTEENTH PICK IN
THE FIRST ROUND AT THE TWO
THOUSAND ONE NBA DRAFT AS A
GRADUATE OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY
AT STANFORD HE WAS AN ALL
AMERICAN AND RANKED FIRST FOR A
FIELD GOAL PERCENTAGE AND THIRD
IN BLOCKED SHOTS.
COLLINS PLAYED CENTER FOR SIX
NBA TEAMS AND TENSIONS STILL
PLAYOFFS INCLUDING TWO NBA
FINALS.
AT THE END OF THE TWENTY TWELVE
THIRTEEN NBA SEASON.
MISTER COLLINS PUBLICLY CAME OUT
AS GAY AND A COVER STORY FOR
SPORTS ILLUSTRATED.
HE BECAME THE FIRST MALE ACTIVE
PLAYER IN ANY OF THE FOUR MAJOR
AMERICAN PROFESSIONAL SPORTS AND
NOW THAT HE IS GAY.
SINCE ITS MISSION IS TO EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO LIVE THEIR LIVES AS
THEIR TRUE SELVES HIS WORK WITH
NUMEROUS CHARITIES FOUNDATIONS
AN ORGANIZATION.
HE IS ALSO AN NBA CARES
AMBASSADOR AND SPREADS GOODWILL
ON BEHALF OF THE NBA WITH ITS
PLAYERS COMMUNITY AND CORPORATE
PARTNERS WELCOME MR JASON
COLLINS.
WE ALSO WELCOME ALL OTHER
SPECIAL GUESTS WHO JOINED US FOR
THIS OBSERVANCE THIS CONCLUDES
OUR CEREMONY.
AS OUR AUTO REJECTED THE CHAMBER
VIA THE CENTER AISLE LET'S GIVE
THEM ANOTHER HEARTY ROUND
ON THE
DAILY FILE.
THIS IS SECOND READING COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
NINETY NINE WITH THE MOMENT
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN NINETY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS ONE FIFTY
ONE AT THE MOMENT SIX FORTY ONE
THREE TWENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN WITH THE
MOMENT. FIVE THIRTY TO AT THE
MOMENT FIVE EIGHTY NINE AT THE
MOMENT SIX ELEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS AND THREE TWENTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
ON SECOND READING THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO ACR NINETY NINE BY MISTER
LOW.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
LOW AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO CIVIL
RIGHTS.
MR LOW YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF ACR NINETY
NINE IN RECOGNITION ALSO OF EL
TO BE PRIDE MONTH IS A
RESOLUTION.
CONDEMNING CONVERSION THERAPY AS
MANY OF YOU MAY RECALL IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR WE HAD A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THERE IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE TO
QUALIFY CONVERSION THERAPY.
AS WHAT IT IS A FRAUDULENT
PRACTICE AT THE SAME TIME IT
BECAME READILY.
OUT THAT A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WERE IN OPPOSITION THAT FELT
THAT THIS WOULD BAN THE BIBLE
AND AS SUBSEQUENTLY TO THAT --
TYPE OF RHETORIC I FIND MYSELF
VISITING A NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES
DISTRICTS.
INCLUDING THE MEMBER
REPRESENTING THOUSAND OAKS THE
MEMBER REPRESENTING ST BERNARD
YOU KNOW THE MEMBER REPRESENTING
CONCORD AND PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WERE SUCH THAT.
I FOUND THAT THERE WAS AN
UNLIKELY ALLY SHIP THAT WAS
RECOGNIZE WITH RESPECT TO KERN
VERSION THERAPY IN FACT THE
LEADERS THAT I MET WITH.
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
INDIVIDUALS OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
SHOULD BE LOVED AND CELEBRATED
AS WHO THEY ARE AND THAT
CONVERSION THERAPY.
WAS A FRAUDULENT PRACTICE AND A
PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
SPEAKER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IN FACT PART OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
WERE SO FRUITFUL THAT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL EVANGELICAL ASSOCIATION
PENNED AN OP ED IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY REGISTER.
STATING THAT REPAIRED IF THEY'RE
P. IS WITHOUT EVIDENCE AS TO ITS
EFFICACY IT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
CHRISTIAN LIVING.
WE SUPPORT THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS PRACTICE THAT CAUSES HARM
TO THESE INDIVIDUALS THIS IS
CONTRARY TO THE NATURE OF THE
CHRISTIAN MESSAGE.
WHICH WHILE CALLING FOR CHANGE
IN ALL PEOPLE TO BE ORIENTED
TOWARDS CHRIST EVEN AT GREAT
SACRIFICE NEITHER FAVORS NOR
SUPPORTS ANY PRACTICE THAT
CAUSES ANY HARM.
MEMBERS THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE
US IS A SIMPLE RECOGNITION THAT
MEMBERS OF THE LGB COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE LOVED AND CELEBRATED
AS WHO THEY ARE.
BUT IN FACT THIS IS ALSO A
CULMINATION TO ALSO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THIS ENJOYS WIDE SUPPORT
WITH IT WITHIN THE EVANGELICAL
COMMUNITY.
WE FOUND THAT OFTENTIMES WE
WOULD FIND THAT THE LGBT
COMMUNITY WOULD BE AT ODDS WITH
THAT OF EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN
LEADERS BUT WE WE HAVE BEFORE US
HERE TODAY.
IS A CULMINATION OF THE HARD
WORK AND RECOGNIZING THAT ALL
THREE OF CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE
RECOGNIZEDAS WHO THEY ARE AND
AND BRACED -- AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THEY WERE SLOW MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES I LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SILICON
VALLEY FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL
I STAND AS A PROUD.
CO AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND HIM FOR HIS WORK TO
FACILITATE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND CHRISTIAN
LEADERS.
IN ORDER TO DEVELOP THIS
RESOLUTION.
YOU KNOW I'M SURE THAT MANY OF
US CELEBRATED PRIDE MONTH -- BY
PARTICIPATING IN LOCAL PARADES
AND THE COLORS AND THE GLITTER.
AND THE DANCE MUSIC WE'RE ALL
FINE BUT HOPEFULLY WE SAW.
A KALEIDOSCOPIC REPRESENTATION.
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
IN SIZES IN AGES AND RACES AND
ETHNICITIES.
AND PROBABLY WE SAW [inaudible]
HOPE [inaudible]
LOVE [inaudible]
SADNESS STRENGTH.
RESILIENCE AND DETERMINATION.
IN THEIR EYES.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR ONE OF THE
VERY FIRST VOTE THAT I TOOK ON
THIS FLOOR WAS ON CONVERSION
THERAPY.
AND I HADN'T BEEN HERE THAT LONG.
AND I WAS ACTUALLY AGHAST THAT
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WE WERE
STILL TALKING ABOUT.
AND I REMEMBER SHARING THIS AT
BATH SHYING A LOCAL SYNAGOGUE IN
MY COMMUNITY IT IS THE FIRST
LGBT -- Q. SYNAGOGUE FOUNDED IN
THE WORLD.
I SHARED THIS WITH OUR MEMBERS
IN ATTENDANCE.
AND WAS RETURNED.
WITH SADNESS AND GAS THAT THIS
IN FACT WAS SOMETHING.
THAT WE WERE STILL TALKING ABOUT.
AS WE CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WE KNOW
THAT THE CATHOLIC CHURCHIS NOW
STARTING TO OPERATE MORE AND
MORE HOSPITALS.
THAT IS GREAT BECAUSE THAT IS
TALKING ABOUT HAVING GREATER
ACCESS TO CARE.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WHICH
OPERATING THOSE HOSPITALS.
THEY WILL BE SHARING A VERY
PRESCRIPTIVE VALUE SYSTEM.
THAT HAS BEEN RESTRICTIVE
TOWARDS AND BIASED AGAINST WOMEN
AND MEMBERS OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
AS WE BEGAN TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
ARE GOING TO FIND COMPASSION AND
LOVE AND EMPATHY WITH HOW WE
COMMUNICATE.
WITH OUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND OUR
FRIENDS.
LET'S THINK ABOUT THE WORDS THAT
ARE IN THIS RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
AND NO.
THAT THE LIVES OF OUR LGBT Q.
FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS ARE
IMPORTANT.
AT THE EQUAL AND EQUITABLE AND
FAIR TREATMENT OF OUR LGBT Q.
FAMILY FRIENDS.
FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS.
ARE IMPORTANT.
AND LET'S NOT JUST CELEBRATE ON
A DAY AND THEN GO ON ABOUT OUR
BUSINESS.
SCHERING SHAME AND TOLERANCE AND
RESENTMENT.
BECAUSE I'M SURE MANY OF US HAVE
HAD TO FACE THE SAME KIND OF
GOOD DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES
AND FEELINGS THAT WE KNOW.
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND OUR
FRIENDS IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY
HAVE EXPERIENCED.
I WANT TO SHARE THAT -- MY
COUSIN COUSIN BUZZY.
LONG AGO -- HE WAS A FLIGHT
ATTENDANT AND LIVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND HE WAS GAY.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW HE WAS GAY.
I'M BECAUSE I WAS TOO LITTLE AND
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
BUT WHAT I DID NOTICE WAS THAT
EVERY TIME HE CAME AROUND ALL OF
THE WOMEN IN MY FAMILY.
WOULD RUSH TO MAKE SURE THAT HE
HAD WHAT HE NEEDED WOULD EMBRACE
HIM WOULD HANG WITH HIM AND
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT HE HAD THE
LOVE AND SUPPORT THAT HE NEEDED.
AND WHAT I REALIZED LATER ON WAS.
IT WAS BECAUSE HE WAS GAY.
AND HE HAD BEEN ERASED.
FROM OUR FAMILY TREE.
BY HIS FATHER SOMEONE WHO DID
NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANT. TO
HAVE AND LOVE BLACKS OUT.
BUT HE DIED YEARS LATER FROM
COMPLICATIONS OF AIDS.
BUT HE ALSO DIED OF A BROKEN
HEART.
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS RESOLUTION
AND WHAT PRIDE MONTH
[inaudible]
FIGHTS AGAINST.
SO AS ASSIST WOMAN.
AS AN ALLY TO THE LGBT COMMUNITY
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON ACR.
NINETY NINE THANK YOU MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
MISS FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS.
IN SUPPORT OF RESOLUTION AND ACR
NINETY NINE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- SPEAKING ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
I THINK IT'S DIFFICULT FOR MANY
OF US BECAUSE THE VERY PRACTICE
OF CONVERSION THERAPY WHICH
STILL HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA.
GOES TO THE HEART.
OF THE DISCRIMINATION THAT HAS
BEEN HOUNDING LGBT PEOPLE
[inaudible] FOR MILLENNIUM.
T. TO PERPETUATE THE IDEA BUT
THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THAT INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS TO BE
OR CAN BE CURED.
CONTINUES THE CYCLE OF SHAME.
OF THE NILE.
A DISCRIMINATION AND IN MANY
CASES OF VIOLENCE.
THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE YEARS.
HOW WE JUST WENT THROUGH A VERY
JOYOUS CEREMONY WERE REAL WE
WERE ABLE TO HONOR PEOPLE?
WHO HAVE BEEN EXCEPTIONAL
CONTRIBUTORS? TO OUR STATE.
AND THEIR CONTRIBUTORS NOT IN
SPITE OF WHERE THEY FALL ON THE
GENDER SPECTRUM.
BUT BECAUSE OF IT [inaudible]
AND TO HAVE THE IDEA THAT THAT
PART OF THEM SHOULD BE A RACE OR
DENIED.
WHATEVER ROBBED US OF THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS MADE.
WATCHING THE CEREMONY I WAS
THINKING BACK TO WHEN I WAS
YOUNG.
MY VERY BEST FRIEND GROWING UP.
WHEN I WAS A GIRL?
WAS A LESBIAN NOW.
NONE OF US SPOKE OF THAT NONE OF
US REALLY KNEW I MEAN.
THIS WAS FLORIDA THIS WAS MANY
YEARS AGO.
WHEN I WENT?
TO MY HIGH SCHOOL.
HOMECOMING DANCE IS A SENIOR.
THE BOY THAT I TOOK TO THE DANCE
WAS GAY.
AGAIN NOTHING THAT WAS SPOKEN
BUT WE KNOW.
WE KNOW THAT NOTHING WILL COME
OF THAT NIGHT BEYOND FRIENDSHIP.
BUT I WAS THINKING ABOUT THOSE
TWO INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT THEIR
LIVES MUST HAVE BEEN LIKE AT
THAT TIME. TO KNOW THAT THEY
WERE LIVING A LIE.
AND TO BE AFRAID OF BEING
EXPOSED TO BE SO AFRAID THAT
THEY HAD TO DATE.
IN MY CASE A GIRL.
MY GIRLFRIEND'S CASE BOYS.
WHEN THAT WAS CERTAINLY THE LAST
PERSON THEY WANTED TO BE DATING?
AND TO THINK THAT ON TOP OF THAT
THERE WAS SOMEONE WHO MIGHT HAVE
TOLD THEM THAT THEY COULD BE
CURED.
AS THOUGH THEY HAD SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THEM.
AND WHAT THAT WOULD HAVE MEANT
TO THEM.
AND THAT'S TE HORROR THAT WE
STILL PUT PEOPLE THROUGH TODAY.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING SO
FUNDAMENTALLY.
GROSS ABOUT THAT.
AND SAD ABOUT THAT.
SO I WANT TO AGAIN APPLAUD.
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM SILICON
VALLEY'S EFFORTS TO END THIS
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND A
WAY [inaudible] TWO HAVE PEOPLE
REALIZE THAT NOT ONLY SHOULD
THEY SUBJECT THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS TO
CONVERSION THERAPY.
BUT THAT THEY SHOULD.
WHEN THEY HEAR ABOUT IT SAY OH
MY GOD IS THAT A BORING PRACTICE
STILL HAPPEN?
IN OUR MIDST.
THANK YOU AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS FRIEDMAN MIS RACE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR.
NINETY NINE AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SILICON
VALLEY FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
WHEN WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY LAST
YEAR TO VOTE [inaudible]
ON LEGISLATION.
MY COLLEAGUE WENT TO MY
COMMUNITY TO SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE RELIGIOUS LEADERS.
AND I APPRECIATED SO MUCH.
NOT ONLY HIS WILLINGNESS TO COME
TO THE COMMUNITY.
BUT ALSO THE LEADER'S
WILLINGNESS TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE
AN HONEST CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH.
INTEREST IN PROTECTING
VULNERABLE CITIZENS DECEPTIVE.
PRACTICES [inaudible]
CONVERSION THERAPY.
IS ONE OF THOSE PRACTICES.
AND TO BE CLEAR IT'S PROVEN TO
BE AN UNETHICAL AND ULTIMATELY
HARMFUL.
BEING LGBT Q. IS NOT A DISEASE.
IT'S NOT A DISORDER IS NOT AN
ILLNESS THAT NEEDS TO BE CURED.
I SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUES CALL FOR
THE EQUITABLE TREATMENT.
OF ALL PEOPLE.
PROMOTION OF THE IDEA THE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
CAN OR SHOULD BE CHANGED DOES
NOT DEMONSTRATE THE BASIC
RESPECT.
THAT WE SHOULD SHOW ALL PEOPLE.
REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY CHOOSE TO
LOVE. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK ADDRESS MISS KOREA
[inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RIGHTS AND PROUD
SUPPORT IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LET THE NO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
IN SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY NINE A
RESOLUTION THAT EMBRACES THE
DIVERSITY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
FOR FAR TOO LONG OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN REGULATED
RELEGATED TO SHADOWS IN CLOSETS
FEARING SOCIAL STIGMA AND
PERSECUTION. FOR BEING WHO THEY
ARE.
STATE MY HAS FOSTERED DAMAGING
PRACTICES LIKE CONVERSION
THERAPY.
WHICH TEACHES LGBTQ PEOPLE TO
RESENT THEIR AUTHENTIC AND
BEAUTIFUL IDENTITIES LABELING
THEM AS PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
CHANGE.
NOT ONLY DO THESE PRACTICES
CAUSE HARM TO THE LGBT Q.
INDIVIDUALS BUT ALSO CONTRIBUTE
TO A LARGER CULTURE OF INJUSTICE.
AND DISCRIMINATION.
THIS CULTURE HAS FATAL
CONSEQUENCES AS SHOWN IN THE
TRAGIC MASS SHOOTING.
AT THE POLLS NIGHT CLUB IN
ORLANDO FLORIDA WHICH TOOK THE
LIVES OF FORTY NINE PEOPLE.
AND WOUNDED FIFTY THREE OTHERS
MOST OF WHOM WERE LGBT Q. LATINO
INDIVIDUALS.
DESPITE THE INJUSTICES AGAINST
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
THE COMMUNITY HAS OVERCOME EACH
AND EVERY OBSTACLE IN STRIDE AND
I OUT ARE UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT
THEIR FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
AND IDENTITY.
ON THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
STONE WALL.
WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR SCHOOL
CURRICULUM ADDED A THIRD GENDER
OPTION IN OUR STATE ID'S.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST LGBT
Q. LEGISLATORS IN THE NATION.
IN THE SPIRIT I LIKE TO MENTION
THE REVOLUTIONARY WORK OF SYLVIA
HE BETTER.
A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD PORTER
RICAN DRAG QUEEN WHO USE HER
VOICE TO INFORM AND TRANSFORM.
THE LGBT Q. MOVEMENT AND PUT THE
VOICE OF TRANS WOMEN AND TRANS
WOMAN OF COLOR.
AT THE FOREFRONT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE AND WHO STORY WITHIN
STONE WALL IS ONLY NOW BEING
TOLD BY THOSE THAT CAME AFTER
HER.
LIKE BAMBI SAYS HELLO FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO NOW RUNS THE
NATIONAL TRENDS LET THE NOT
COALITION.
ADDING PERSPECTIVE AN
INTERSECTION NOW READY TO THE
TRANS IMMIGRANT UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY WHO EVERY DAY CONTINUE
TO FIGHT FOR RECOGNITION AND
JUSTICE THE PURSUIT.
OF THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS.
AND ALSO IN THAT SPIRIT AND THE
SPIRIT OF THOSE TIMES A
REVOLUTION OF THE LATE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
I LIKE TO GIVE A PERSONAL SHOUT
OUT OF LOVE AND APPRECIATION TO
THE LGBT Q. PATRONS OF THE BLACK
CAT TAVERN.
IN THE SILVER LAKE NEIGHBORHOOD
OF EIGHTY FIFTY ONE THE TWO
YEARS PRIOR TO STONE WALL WERE
HARASSED AND BEATEN BY POLICE
SIMPLY FOR KISSING.
DURING A NEW YEAR'S EVE
CELEBRATION.
IN RESPONSE THE COMMUNITY
PROTEST THAT FOR THEIR CIVIL
RIGHTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS WERE
FELT ACROSS THE NATION WHICH LED
TO STONE WALL. TO HONOR THOSE
BEFORE US WE THE MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY MUST FOSTER A
CLIMATE OF INCLUSIVITY
INTERSECTION NOW LADY.
AN ADVOCATE FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY UNTIL ALL MEMBERS ARE
HEARD SEEN AND CELEBRATED
BECAUSE LOVE IS LOVE IS LOVE IS
LOVE NO MATTER WHO OR WHERE YOU
WORSHIP.
AS A PROUD ALLY.
KLAY REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON
ACR.
NINETY NINE THE MYSTERY OF
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE AS A PROUD MEMBER THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AND ALSO AS A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER WHO WAS
DONE.
A LOT OF WORK WITH INDIVIDUALS
OVER THE WORLD OVER THE WORLD
OVER MY LIFE -- BUT I GUESS I
JUST WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO THE
VOICES SPEAKING TODAY.
THAT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE BASED
TYPES OF CONVERSION THERAPY THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS TIME
TRIED AND TRUE AND TESTED WE
KNOW IT IS -- ACTUALLY IS
DANGEROUS IT IS COUNTER
INTUITIVE -- AND I THINK IT
SPEAKS TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER ISSUES AROUND ADDICTION
ISSUES AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
IS YOUR OWN SELF DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIORS THAT OFTEN COME FROM A
DEEP PLACE THAT LIVES INSIDE
SOMEBODY WHO SAYS I'M NOT OKAY.
THAT I NEED TO BE CHANGED THAT
MY COMMUNITY CAN'T SEE ME AS WHO
I AM FOR THE AS A AS WE HEARD
FROM OTHER ARE CHAPLAIN THE ONE
IN SIX TRILLION PERSON.
IN THE WORLD THAT IS JUST YOU
THAT IS BORN JUST TELL YOU ARE
TO LOVE JUST TO YOU LOVE AND TO
BE LOVED FOR WHO YOU ARE -- AND
CONTINUE ON WITH THINGS LIKE
CONVERSION THERAPIES TELLS ALL
THE UNCLE BUDDIES OF THE WORLD
THAT THEY DON'T BELONG THAT THEY
ARE NOT GOOD ENOUGH THAT
SOMETHING IN THEM IS WRONG.
AND MUST BE CHANGED WE WANT TO
REBUKE THAT WITH OUR HARSHEST
VOICE TO SAY THAT IS NOT THE WAY
FOR ANY OF US TO LIVE OUR FULL
AND TRUEST LIFE THE WAY WE LIVE
OUR FULL AND TRUEST LIFE IS TO
HAVE THOSE AROUND US.
NOT LOOKING AT US AS THOUGH
SOMETHING ABOUT US MUST BE
CHANGED SO THAT WE CAN BE EQUAL
BUT THAT WE STAND SIDE BY SIDE
SHOULDER SUPPORTS SHOULDER AND
HEART TO HEART.
WITH ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE ARE ALL OKAY
AND I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ACR NINETY NINE AGAIN THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE BASED CONVERSION
THERAPY IT IS SIMPLY A PLOY. TO
PREY UPON PEOPLE'S -- MY DEEPEST
FEARS AND DEEPEST INSECURITIES
ABOUT THE DESIRE ONLY TO BE
LOVED AND ACCEPTED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR.
NINETY NINE THANK YOU DR ED BY
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY AS A MOM.
IN STRONG SUPPORT ACR.
NINETY NINE I HAVE TWO SONS THEY
ARE TEN AND TWELVE YEARS OLD
THEY ARE JUST STARTING THEIR
JOURNEY INTO ADULTHOOD.
THEY ARE FINDING OUT WHO THEY
ARE AND WHO THEY'RE GOING TO BE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS THEY ARE
GOING TO FIND THEIR PATH.
THEY'RE GOING TO FIND THEIR
PASSIONS THEY'RE GONNA FALL IN
LOVE FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME.
AND WHAT EVER THAT PATH WHOEVER
THEY ARE I DON'T WANT ANYONE.
ANYONE.
TELLING THEM THAT THEY ARE A
DISEASE THAT NEEDS TO BE CURED
THAT THEY ARE A WRONG.
THAT NEEDS TO BE MADE RIGHT.
THAT THEY ARE A MISSTEP THAT
SO AS A MOM [inaudible]
AND AS A REPRESENTATIVE.
FOR THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I AM VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION AND I TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR TENACITY.
AND YOUR BRAVERY AND BRINGING
THIS FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS PETRIE-NORRIS
MISTER DAVID CHIU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY NINE AS
A CHAIR OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
ARE CAUCUS SUPPORTED LAST YEAR'S
VERSION THIS BILL WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS YEAR'S.
A NUMBER OF YOU HAVE SHARED
PERSONAL STORIES LET ME SHARE A
FEW STATISTICS.
A RECENT STUDY BY THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN FOUNDATION FOUND
THAT ONLY 19%.
OF API LGBT Q. YOUTH FELT THAT
THEY COULD DEFINITELY BE WHO
THEY WERE AT HOME WHICH IS LOWER
THAN THE AVERAGE RESPONSE FROM
LGBT Q. -- YOUTH WERE SURVEYED.
THE NUMBER IS ONLY SLIGHTLY
BETTER IN SCHOOL SETTINGS API
LGBT Q. STUDENTS -- RESPONDED
ONLY AT THE LEVEL OF 29% WHO
SAID THAT THEY COULD BE
DEFINITELY WHO THEY ARE IN
SCHOOLS.
THIS IS A RESOLUTION THAT IS
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE
STATISTICS BY ENCOURAGING ALL OF
US TO EMBRACE ACCEPTANCE AND
EQUITABLE TREATMENT AND WITHOUT
I HOPE THAT YOU CAN SUPPORT ACR.
NINETY NINE MR MAYES HERE
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF THIS -- THIS -- ACR.
NINETY NINE I AM -- THE SON.
OF A PASTOR -- THE GRAND SON OF
A PASTOR.
A GREAT GRANDSON OF A PASTOR MY
GREAT UNCLE.
WAS A PASTOR.
I GROWING UP WENT TO CHURCH
SUNDAY MORNINGS [inaudible]
SUNDAY AFTERNOONS [inaudible]
WEDNESDAY'S [inaudible]
YOUTH GROUP.
AND I'VE SEEN OVER TIME THE
CONFLATION OF OUR POLITICS --
AND AND RELIGION.
AND I THINK UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE BELIEVERS.
IT'S INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO SEE
THIS EMERGENCE OF BETWEEN
RELIGION AND POLITICS AND I
THINK SOME OF US.
INSTEAD OF SHOWING LOVE SHOWED
HATE.
AND THEN OTHER SOCIAL ILLS CAME
UP WITH THIS IDEA OF OF
CONVERSION THERAPY THIS THE
MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY -- IS
NOT ABOUT.
RELIGION IT IS ABOUT LOVE AND IF
I CAN FOR JUST A MOMENT IF I
MIGHT.
A READ MISTER SPEAKER WITHOUT
OBJECTION PREACH FOR JUST A
SECOND IN THE BOOK OF PSALM ONE
THIRTY NINE VERSE FOURTEEN I
PRAISE YOU.
BECAUSE I AM FEARFULLY AND
WONDERFULLY MADE YOUR WORKS ARE
WONDERFUL I KNOW THAT FULL WELL.
WE ARE ALL GOD'S CHILDREN.
WE NEED TO LOVE ONE ANOTHER.
ALSO WHEN I THINK OF THE AUTHOR
FOR ALL OF HIS WORK ON THIS -- I
KNOW FOR FOR YEARS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO HIM AND
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT HE
JUST WANTED TO JAM THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE HE'S LISTENED.
HE'S WORKED HARD HE'S BEEN UP
AND DOWN -- THIS STATE.
I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR HIS WORK
ON THIS AND A STRONG I I URGE
THIS BODY A TO VOTE YES.
THERE WAS REYES WAS POWER CAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR.
NINETY NINE AS THE SISTER OF AN
LGBT Q. MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
WHO REMEMBERS.
SO CLEARLY HOW AFRAID SHE WAS TO
COME OUT TO US. FOR FEAR THAT WE
HER MOST CLOSE CONFIDANTS AND
LOVED ONES WOULD REJECT HER.
AND OF COURSE WE DIDN'T.
WE ACCEPTED HER WE LOVE HER FOR
WHO SHE WAS.
MY RESPONSE WAS WHAT TOOK YOU SO
LONG TO TELL ME.
WHEN DO I GET TO MEET YOUR
GIRLFRIEND?
BUT THAT FEAR IS REAL AND IT WAS
THE ACCEPTANCE THEY MADE HER
FLOURISH SHE HAS BEEN BLESSED
WITH THE RELIGIOUS COMMUNITY
THAT IS ACCEPTED HER.
SHE'S A RABBI SHE'S MARRIED TO A
RABBI.
AND THEY HAVE TWO BEAUTIFUL
DAUGHTERS.
AND IT IS IN THESE MOMENTS THAT
WE GET TO SAY TO OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY WE ACCEPT YOU.
WE LOVE YOU FOR WHO YOU ARE AND
I URGE THIS BODY TODAY WITH THIS
RESOLUTION TO TELL.
EVERY MEMBER OF THE LG TV Q.
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
ACCEPT THEM FOR WHO THEY ARE WE
WILL NOT ASK THEM TO CHANGE.
BUT THAT WE WE OUR THEIR ALLIES
EVERY DAY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR.
NINETY THANK YOU MS BARRICADE
HAND SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE
RESOLUTION MR LOW.
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO.
HAVE -- SPOKE AND AND SHARED.
THEIR THEIR LOVE.
SIMPLY PUT A AND SPECIFICALLY
FROM. TO THE COLLEAGUES FROM YOU
GO VALLEY.
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THAT WE
HAD LAST YEAR ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE FOR
THOSE WHO NOT VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
IT WAS THAT SUCH THAT.
MANY OF YOU SURE CONVERSATIONS
PERHAPS THIS MIGHT GO TOO FAR.
OR COULD WE STILL ALLOW FOR
RELIGIOUS PROTECTIONS WHICH WAS
CLEARLY DEFINED THE BILL BUT WAS
NOT PERHAPS AS THERE V<c.cyan> AND</c>
WITH RESPECT TO THE POSITIONS
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAD -- BUT WHAT
WE HAVE BEFORE US HERE IS THE
RESULT OF A SEEMINGLY DIVERGENT
VIEW POINT TO WHICH WE HAVE
ACTUALLY COME TOGETHER AND
STATED OUR COLLECTIVE INTEREST
IN THE PUBLIC GOOD OF PROTECTING
INDIVIDUALS.
AGAIN TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE AM CONVERSION THERAPY AS A
FRAUDULENT PRACTICE FLEW OUT OF
THIS BODY.
IT ALSO FLEW OFF THE SENATE
FLOOR AND WAS READY FOR THE
GOVERNOR SIGNATURE.
BUT MANY OF YOU SAID.
PLEASE WOULD YOU PAUSE BECAUSE
WE JUST FEEL LIKE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY PERHAPS HAVE SOME
RESERVATIONS SOME CONCERNS.
SO IN FACT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE DID.
WE PULLED THE BILL.
AWAY FROM THE GOVERNOR SIGNATURE
AND THAT LAW WAS NOT PUT BEFORE
THE GOVERNOR. FOR HIS APPROVAL.
NOW I DON'T KNOW ABOUT MANY OF
YOU BUT HOW HOW MANY LEGISLATORS.
WOULD WORK SO HARD TO PUT ALL OF
THEIR TIME ENERGY AND EFFORT.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH JUST TO PULL
IT AWAY.
BUT I HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
PARTICULARLY FOR MEMBERS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE I HAVE
HEARD YOU.
I'VE HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
THAT WE MUST WORK
COLLABORATIVELY PARTICULARLY
THIS ENVIRONMENT. TO HELP BUILD
THE LEVEL OF TRUST RESPECT
REPORT READ THE RESOLUTION.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
RESOLUTION SAYS THAT WE SHOULD
BE AN INCLUSIVE SOCIETY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
SO IF YOU HAD RESERVATIONS AND
DID NOT VOTE FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE LAST
YEAR ON CONVERSION THERAPY.
AS IT FRAUDULENT PRACTICE
BECAUSE IT WOULD GO TOO FAR.
THEN YOU SHOULD VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE THIS
RESOLUTION TALKS ABOUT THE T.
ESSENCE OF WHICH YOU SHARED WITH
ME PERSONALLY ONE ON ONE THAT
THIS IS A NON BINDING RESOLUTION
BUT IN FACT YOU ALSO BELIEVE IN
BASIC.
LOVE IN THE PADDY AND RESPECT
JUST LIKE EVERYONE ELSE THIS IS
WHY WE CELEBRATE PRIDE.
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS GROWING UP.
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO THINK.
ABOUT SUICIDE.
AND THE DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT
OF SUICIDE THE PERCENTAGE OF
SUICIDE AMONG LGBT YOUTH.
I DO NOT WANT TO SEE A YOUNGER
EVAN LOW.
IN WHICH I THOUGHT ABOUT SUICIDE
AND WHEN MY PARENTS MY FATHER
WHO THEM THOMAS AS A DOCTOR ALSO
SAID.
PERHAPS WE CAN SEEK OUT
CONVERSION THERAPY PERHAPS WE
SHOULD IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE AND
YOU WOULD BE I DO NOT WANT YOU
TO BE SUBJECTED TO THE ADVOCATE
THAT EXIST IN THIS WORLD HE KNEW
THAT.
IT DOESN'T WORK BUT YET.
HE WAS A LOVING FATHER AND SAID
I WANT TO HELP YOU AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
BUT AS IN WE ARE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN NOW LET US PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY A BLUEPRINT. FOR THE
NATION THIS IS A TRANSFORMATIVE
EFFORT TO BUILD BRIDGES FOR ALL
PEOPLE.
IN WHICH YOU DEMONSTRATE THE
COURAGE OF OUR LOVE SO WITH
RESPECT.
I PARTICULARLY THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEGE WHO HAS SPOKEN IN
SUPPORT WHO PREVIOUSLY SAID
SUPPORTED.
CONVERSION THERAPY AS A
FRAUDULENT PRACTICES AND I'M
FLOOR.
AND THERE SAID BAG. FOR MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE TO ALSO JOIN US HAND
IN HAND JUST AS SO MANY OTHER
EVANGELICAL AND CHRISTIAN
LEADERS HAVE DONE SO IN THIS
EFFORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE MISS LOW
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
FIRST ROLL THE ROLE WILL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS COUPLE OF
THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
NINETY NINE THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ADDING ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY
AGE CO AUTHOR SAT IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MOVING VERY BRIEFLY BACK
TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MISTER
GIBSON IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER FROM MY DESK FOR HIS
SPECIAL PRESENTATION MR GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE.
THE SIXTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THERE ARE VERY OWN --
JOSEPHINE IN A COOL UP.
WHO WAS ELECTED AS THE?
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PROJECT
LEADER LEAD THE WAY P. L. T. W.
LARGE TEACHER OF THE YEAR.
SHE IS ONE OF COMPTON'S BASS.
ONE OUT OF SIX ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES TO RECEIVE A TOP
RECOGNITION.
MISTER COOL AS A MODEL OF
EMPOWER MEANT FOR EACH STUDENT.
AT JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
LOCATED IN COMPTON CALIFORNIA.
SHE HAS HER OWN OUTSTANDING
SERVICE RECORD.
AS AN EDUCATOR [inaudible]
A SPECIALIST.
AND HAS LED EFFORTS TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AT HER SCHOOL WITH THESE YOUNG
SCHOLARS.
SHE'S AN EXPERT IN STEM.
PASSION FOR ACADEMICS EXCELLENCE
AND A TIRELESS LEADER WHO HAS
HELPED TRANSFORM.
JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL INTO
AN EQUITABLE TEACHING AND
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
STUDENTS MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT.
THIS RESOLUTION. TO JOSEPHINA.
NICOLA TODAY FOR HER BEING AN
OUTSTANDING TEACHER.
MEMBERS YOU PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME MISS NICOLE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
THIS IS SB.
ONE OH FOUR SB ONE OF FOUR I MAY
STAND CORRECTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED
IN NUMERICAL ORDER.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
WILL BE SB.
SEVENTY FIVE SB [inaudible]
SEVENTY FIVE CORPORATION.
THE BILL SEVENTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO EDUCATION
FINANCE MAKING YOUR PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
YOU'RE TAKING YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
SEVENTY FIVE AND IS THAT THIS
TIONAL EDUCATION TRAILER BILL.
REGARDS THROUGH K. THROUGH
TWELVE ESTABLISHES A SPECIAL
EDUCATION EARLY INTERVENTION
PRESCHOOL GRANT INCREASES
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING.
IT PROVIDES ALMOST A NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT.
PROGRAM.
ESTABLISHES THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM
RAY PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH IN THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SYSTEM.
IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
IMPACTED BY THE RECENT WILD
FIRES TO RECEIVE A TWO YEAR
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE HOLD
HARMLESS.
RECENT MEASUREMENTS ELIMINATE
THE REQUIREMENT FOR QUALIFYING
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO BE SERVING AT
LEAST 50% OF STUDENTS BEFORE THE
EMERGENCY.
IN REGARDS TO EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANDS TO PRESCHOOL AGE ABILITY
TO INCLUDE ALL THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS IN LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS.
CREATES THE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANT PROGRAM FOR
CHILDCARE REALLY EDUCATION
PROVIDERS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM FOR
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES.
I WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE FOR SB.
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
TANG MISTER OF REALTY MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVENTY FIVE MEMBERS THIS
BILL CONTINUES THE ASSAULT ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENT STATE LAW PERMITS ANY
SCHOOL A PUBLIC MAGNET SCHOOL OR
A CHARTER SCHOOL TO ENFORCE
ACADEMIC STANDARDS ON ADMISSIONS
THIS TRAILER BILL WOULD TAKE
THAT ABILITY AWAY FROM CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN FACT.
UNDER THIS TRAILER BILL CHARTER
SCHOOLS WOULD NOT EVEN BE ABLE
TO REQUEST AN ACADEMIC
TRANSCRIPT OF SOMEONE WHO
APPLIES TO THEIR PROGRAM.
SIMILARLY UNDER CURRENT STATE
LAW A PUBLIC MAGNET SCHOOL OR A
CHARTER SCHOOL MAY ENFORCE
ACADEMIC STANDARDS ON ITS
STUDENTS.
THIS WILL WOULD PROHIBIT IT JUST
A CHARTER SCHOOL BERMAN FORCING
THOSE STANDARDS EDISON ROLLING A
STUDENT BECAUSE THEY FOUGHT
FAILED TO MEET THE STANDARDS.
PUBLIC MAGNET SCHOOLS ND
SPECIAL SCHOOL DISTRICT PROGRAMS
WOULD STILL BE ALLOWED TO DO
THIS.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WILL
SERIOUSLY DEGRADE THE
EDUCATIONAL DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND SERIOUSLY IMPACT
THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION AND CAL
CALIFORNIA I URGE A NO VOTE.
THEY WERE SHOWING ALL THE MISS
WALDRON IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER ATTACK ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS BASED ON THE
FALSE PREMISE THE CHARTER SCHOOL
SKIM ONLY THE BEST STUDENTS AND
PUSH OUT LOW PERFORMING CHILDREN.
DESPITE ALLOWING MAGNET SCHOOLS
AND SPECIALIZED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PROGRAMS TO SET ADMISSION
STANDARDS.
THIS BILL UNFAIRLY SINGLES OUT
CHARTER'S BY PREVENTING THEM
FROM USING THE VERY SAME
PRACTICE.
IF ADMISSION STANDARDS AREOKAY
FOR MAGNET SCHOOLS WHY ARE WE
ATTEMPTING TO TREAT CHARTERS
DIFFERENTLY.
THIS BILL WILL NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS FACING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IT'S NOTHING MORE THAN
ANOTHER ATTACK ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND ITS DISTRACTION.
FROM BADLY NEEDED REFORM EFFORTS
THAT WILL GIVE ALL CHILDREN THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE.
I ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEE RECOGNITION.
IS TAKING MY CLOTHES WE WISH.
WITH THAT CLARK LIBERALS.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE AYES.
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MISTER PASSES IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL.
TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS SB.
SEVENTY EIGHT SB.
SEVENTY EIGHT CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACT LIKE THE HEALTH
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER KAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
THE FIRST OF TWO HEALTH TRAILER
BILLS -- FIRST THIS BILL FINALLY
RESTORES CUTS TO THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM MADE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION -- THESE CUTS BEEN
LONG OVERDUE AS SPECIFICALLY
RESTORING -- CUTS REGARDING MEDI
CAL BENEFITS INCLUDING.
OPTICAL PODIATRY AUDIOLOGY IN
SPEECH THERAPY.
ADDITIONALLY WERE ALSO.
DOING RESTORATION TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AS PART OF CREATING NEW
PREVENTION PROGRAMS FOR HIV AND
STDS.
AND THEN LASTLY WE ARE
AUTHORIZING THE REINSTATEMENT OF
THAT INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY
AND PROVIDES INCREASES IN
SUBSIDIES FOR HEALTH COVERAGE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THESE PENALTIES WILL GO TO
ENSURE THAT MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE ABLE TO
AFFORD HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SUBSIDIES WILL BE
PROVIDED FOR PEOPLE BETWEEN
410026100% OF FEDERAL POVERTY
WHICH FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR'S
INCOME.
BETWEEN APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
CALIFORNIA HAS PROJECTED THAT
THESE NEW SUBSIDIES WHAT IMPACT
ALMOST A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
AND HELP THEM GET THE HEALTH
CARE ACCESS THAT THEY DESERVE.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE FOR SB.
SEVENTY THINGS TING MISTER OF
ROYALTY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A MANDATE THAT EVERYONE
IN CALIFORNIA MUST PURCHASE
HEALTH INSURANCE AND CREATE A
PENALTY FOR THOSE WHO FAIL TO
ACHIEVE THAT.
THAT PENALTY REVENUE WILL BE
USED TO PROVIDE SUBSIDIES TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO PURCHASE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THOSE
SUBSIDIES WILL GO THE MAJORITY
OF THE SUBSIDY REVENUE WILL BE
SPENT. FOR PEOPLE ABOVE 4100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND
ELIGIBILITY FOR THOSE SUBSIDIES
WILL EXTEND ALL THE WAY UP
26100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
SO TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE
6100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL RIGHT NOW IS AN INCOME OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR A SINGLE PERSON.
OR ALMOST A HUNDRED AND HIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE IF YOU LOOK AT
THE STATISTICS FOR THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHEN IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN CALIFORNIA THE
PEOPLE PREDOMINANTLY THE PAID
THE PENALTY IS.
WERE YOUNG HEALTHY PEOPLE WITH
AN INCOME OF EITHER BETWEEN
THIRTY THOUSAND AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO THIS TRAILER BILL IF WE PASS
IT TODAY WE'LL TAKE MONEY AWAY
FROM PEOPLE MAKING THIRTY TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND GIVE IT TO PEOPLE MAKING
BETWEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR COLLEAGUES THAT
MAKES NO SENSE I REGIONAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS ROAD ONLY SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM YES.
DR AMULET HERE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IN RESPONSE TO THE CRITIQUE FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
OCCURS TODAY TO SOME PEOPLE. FOR
A COUPLE WHO ARE IN THEIR EARLY
SIXTIES COULD SPEND AS MUCH AS
40% OF THEIR INCOME CURRENTLY ON
HEALTH CARE.
AFTER WHAT WE SEE IN
AFFORDABILITY THAT COMES IN A
SUBSEQUENT TRAILER BILL SB ONE
OF SIX WE WILL CAP THAT AT 18%
OF INCOMES THAT CAN BE SPENT ON
PREMIUMS.
THAT'S STILL A LOT OF MONEY BUT
IT'S MUCH LESS THAN THEY'RE
CURRENTLY SPENDING NOW. TWO
SEPARATE STUDIES HAVE USED
DIFFERENT MICRO SIMULATION
MODELS AS WELL.
WHICH WOULD SHOW THAT WE COULD
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA BY UP TO A HUNDRED
AND NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AS WE INCREASE THE PREMIUM
OBSESS ASSISTANCE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING.
UNTIL NOW PROVIDING
AFFORDABILITY HAS HAD A STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I URGE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL.
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR.
NOW SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES.
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB.
SEVENTY NINE COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY MENTAL
HEALTH CLEARING THE URGENCY
THERE OF TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER CHANG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ESPYS
SEVENTY NINE EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE FOR COUNTIES TO EXPAND.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACTIVATION FUNDING. TO A
DEADLINE ESTABLISHED BY.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
THIS IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT
NOT EVERY SIZE FITS ALL IN TERMS
OF THE DEADLINE FOR LARGE
COUNTIES IN SMALL COUNTIES SO
THAT THE DEADLINES WILL NOW BE
DONE BY THE COMMISSION ON A MORE
CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THE BILL ALSO REMOVES THE
PROHIBITION ON THE USE OF STATE
FUNDS IN THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAM UNDER THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
REFLECTING INACTION TO
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUNDS FOR THIS PURPOSE
IN THE BUDGET BILL.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THEY WERE SITTING WILSHIRE
OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY NINE
THIS TRAILER BILL WILL PREVENT
THE NEEDLESS REVERSION OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE ACCOUNT FUNDS
FROM A COUNTIES BACK TO THE
STATE.
THIS ACTION WILL HELP COUNTIES A
METER MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
NEEDS IRISH AN AYE VOTE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
TURNS OUT OF VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRABLE [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
HELLO I SEVENTY FIVE DOES YOUR
ON THE URGENCY.
I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE.
THAT BUDGET BILL PASSES IT
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO BE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB.
ONE OH FOUR CORPORATION SENATE
BILL ONE OF FOR BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AND
ACTUALLY TO HELP MAKE IT A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATE
TO THE BUDGET.
MR TANK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB ONE AFFORDS OUR SECOND HEALTH.
TRAILER BILL THIS BILL HELPS
GIVE US A LITTLE BIT CLOSER TO
OUR GOAL OF UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILLS ON PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE ACTION WE HAD OF
OFFERING MEDI CAL TO YOUNG
PEOPLE UP TO EIGHTEEN REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS THIS WILL
EXPAND.
THAT AGE RANGE FROM EIGHTEEN UP
TILL THAT INDIVIDUAL IS TWENTY
SIX YEARS OLD.
WE BELIEVE THIS WILL IMPACT
ABOUT A HUNDRED A THOUSAND YOUNG
PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHILE THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WARNER ISSUE BEFORE WALL WILL
NOW HAVE ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE.
NOW HAVE ACCESS TO VACCINATIONS
NOW HAVE ACCESS TO MUCH OF THE
HEALTH CARE THAT MOST OF US TAKE
VERY MUCH FOR GRANTED.
IN ADDITION THE BILL ALSO SEEKS
TO HELP OUR LOW INCOME SENIORS
WHO.
WILL NOT LOSE THEIR MEDI CAL
COVERAGE WHEN THEY REACH THE AGE
OF SIXTY FIVE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIED VOTE ON
SB.
ONE OH FOUR THEY WHICH TAKE
MISTER OF REALTY MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN OPPOSITION SB -- ONE
FOR THIS TRAILER BILL PROPOSES A
SUBSTANTIAL -- INCREASING
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDICARE ALL AND
THAT INCREASE WILL COME AT A
SUBSTANTIAL COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TESTIFIED
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS MORNING.
THAT THE PER CAPITA COST TO THE
STATE OF THESE NEW ENROLLEES
WILL BE SUBSTANTIALLY MORE THAN
IT SPENDS CURRENTLY ON A WOMAN
IN MEDI CAL THAT'S BECAUSE THESE
ARE ENROLLEES THAT ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR A FEDERAL MATCH.
FOR THEIR HEALTHCARE DOLLARS.
I ALSO FEEL THAT WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO FIX MEDI CAL FOR
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
DEPEND ON IT NOW BEFORE WE TALK
ABOUT EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY FOR
IT.
I GET PHONE CALLS EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE FROM
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE COVERED BY
MEDICARE ALL BUT OR ILL AND ARE
UNABLE TO SEE A DOCTOR.
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE SO FEW
DOCTORS IN MY DISTRICT ARE ABLE
TO TAKE THE LOW REIMBURSEMENTS
THAT MEDI CAL PROVIDES THEM.
AND THEREFORE VERY FEW
OPPORTUNITIES EXIST FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS TO GET ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE COLLEAGUES WE NEED
TO FIX THOSE PROBLEMS FIRST AND
MAKE SURE WERE FROM FILLING THE
PROMISES THAT WE MADE. TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA'S
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY I REGIONAL VOTE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OF KIRK
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES IN WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE.
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB.
ONE OH SIX CARBURETOR.
SENATE BILL ONE OH SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
BUDGET MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
MR TING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB ONE
OH SIX A MAN'S THE BUDGET BILL
WHICH WE PASSED ON THURSDAY JUNE
THIRTEENTH INAPPROPRIATE.
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ASSUMED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET PACKAGE A HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE MILLION OF WHICH IS FOR
ADDITIONAL HEALTH BENEFITS UP
SEATS WHICH WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS. EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY ALMOST FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR YOU SEE AND
THAT'S TO SUPPORT.
THE IN STATE CALIFORNIA
ENROLLMENT AT THOSE INSTITUTIONS
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION.
SIX POINT SIX MILLION FOR THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL
IN FIVE MILLION FOR THE MASTER
PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB ONE OF SIX THINGS
CHANGE YOUR OBERNOLTE MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE OH SIX THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE NEEDED FUNDING
AUGMENTATIONS TO SUPPORT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT BOTH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CSU THIS BILL OR PROVIDE
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UC
AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CAL STATE.
THIS FUNDING AUGMENTATION IS
BADLY NEEDED I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF NO THE SCENE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRED ABOUT [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED UP I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
I WAS REMOVED TO TAKE UP AN ITEM
ON THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY TWO SB [inaudible]
FOUR SIXTY NINE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HORSE RACING TO
CLAIM THEIR TO SEE THEIR UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR GRAY MAIL BUT HEY MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB FOUR SIX NINE
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD. TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND A HORSE RACING LICENSE.
IN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
HORSES OR JOCKEYS ARE AT RISK
THE BILL ADDITIONALLY.
EXEMPTS FROM THE BAGLEY KEENE
ACT THE TEN DAY NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT ALLOWING THE BOARD
TO TAKE SWIFT ACTION TO ADDRESS
EMERGING SITUATIONS.
RECENT EVENTS HAVE DEMONSTRATED.
THAT EXISTING HORSE RACING Là
LIMITS THE ABILITY OF THE BOARD
TO ACT SWIFTLY QUICKLY AND TO
ADDRESS ADDRESS IMPORTANT SAFETY
CONCERNS.
AS WELL NO HORSE RACING AS A
RICH HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA
PROVIDES THOUSANDS OF JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOWEVER THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE HORSES AND JOCKEYS MUST
REMAIN A PRIORITY.
NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE
THOUGHTFUL CHANGES THAT WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THE HORSES AND
JOCKEYS ARE PROTECTED AND THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS IN THE COUNTRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLICK LOVE THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY FIVE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY FIVE NO.
ZERO ON THE BILL.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
HI MR GRAY FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR
YEAH I RESPECTFULLY -- REQUEST
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE OF
AN ITEM ON THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY THREE AC A FOURTEEN BY
MISS GONZALES.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FOURTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AC A FOURTEEN IS SIMPLY A
RESOLUTION THAT ASKS THE VOTERS
WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENSURE ALL
WORKERS WHO PERFORM SUPPORT
SERVICES.
AT THE UC ARE AFFORDED THE SAME
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
STANDARDS AS YOU SEE EMPLOYER
HE'S.
BEYOND PROVIDING WORLD CLASS
INSTRUCTION AND RESEARCH AT ITS
CAMPUSES A MEDICAL CENTERS THE
YOU SEE IS THE STATE'S THIRD
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN AS AN ANCHOR
IN THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH IT
OPERATES.
IN RECENT YEARS THE UC HAS
OUTSOURCED AN ESTIMATED SEVEN
THOUSAND SUPPORT JOBS WHAT THE
SAME TIME INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF HIGHLY PAID ADMINISTRATORS TO
APPROXIMATELY.
EIGHT THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THIS
RESULTED IN ANNUAL GONNA STATE
STRAIGHT OF PAYROLL COST
INCREASES OF APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS AMOUNT MATCHES WHAT YOU SEE
IS PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED WOULD
COST OFFER OUTSOURCED WORKERS
THE FULL PROTECTIONS IN EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS
ENJOYED BY YOU SEE EMPLOYEES.
ACA FOURTEEN WILL PROTECT
SERVICE WORKERS THAT YOU SEE
FROM POLICIES THAT PRODUCE
ECONOMIC RACIAL AND GENDER
DISCRIMINATION.
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS RELATED
TO THE NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY TO
HANDLE EITHER MEDICAL
EMERGENCIES OR UNANTICIPATED
NEEDS.
ANYWHERE IN THE UC SYSTEM WE DID
TAKE A MOMENT SAID INCORPORATE
UC'S CURRENT POLICIES FOR THE
USE OF TEMPORARY PER DIEM
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES. TO BE
CLEAR NEITHER THE LEGISLATURE
NOR THE GOVERNOR CAN ADDRESS A
SYSTEMATIC INEQUITIES THAT OCCUR
DUE TO THE YOU SEE THE TANAMI
UNDER ARTICLE NINE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
HOWEVER ARTICLE TO THE
CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
LEGISLATURE THE POWER AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALLOW VOTERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE.
I SIMPLY ASK THAT YOU ALLOW THE
VOTERS TO DECIDE WHETHER LOW
INCOME SERVICE WORKERS THAT YOU
SEE.
THOSE WHO CLEAN THE TOILETS
MOWING THE LAWN SERVE OUR FOOD
AND CLEAN THE BED PANS SHOULD
ENJOY THE SAME STANDARDS ENJOYED
BY YOU SEE EMPLOYEES DOING THE
SAME EXACT WORK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
I THINK IT IS BECAUSE OFFICER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IS CHAIR OF LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE ARISE THE PROPERTIES
WERE CO AUTHOR IS A FOURTEEN
AUTHORED.
BY OUR COLLEAGUE OF SAN DIEGO --
AS SHE STATED AC FOURTEEN WILL
DIRECTLY ASK OUR VOTERS WITH THE
WE SHOULD PROTECT THE LOWEST
WAGE WORKERS AT THE UC.
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE UC
SYSTEM HAS TURNED UNFETTERED
OUTSOURCING OF LOW WAGE WORK
WITH PROMISES OF COST
CONTAINMENT AND PROCUREMENT
BENEFITS.
HOWEVER.
WHEN THE STATE AUDITOR REVIEWED
TEN OF THESE CONTRACTS THEY TELL
OF THE UC LACKED ADEQUATE
DOCUMENTATION TO SUBSTANTIATE?
NINE OF THE TEN BENEFITS
REVIEWED AND THE LOW WAGE
OUTSOURCED WORKERS AT THE UC
IRVINE EARLY THREE DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY SIX CENTS LOWER AN HOURLY
WAGES ON AVERAGE.
THAN UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES DOING
SIMILAR WORK.
ONLY THE VOTERS CAN CORRECT
THESE INEQUITIES AN ACA FOURTEEN
EMPOWERS VOTERS WITH THE
NECESSARY CHANGES IN THE UC
SYSTEM THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I BO.
THERE WAS KALRA MISTER MCCARTY.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT. THREE
YEARS AGO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A BILL AB
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT WHICH I
AUTHORED. TO CRACK DOWN ON THIS
YOU SEE OUTSOURCING HOWEVER
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CAN DO THINGS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY -- THE
PRACTICE HAS CONTINUED SO THIS
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDES US AN
OPPORTUNITY FOLLOW UP ON THAT GO
TO THE VOTERS AND MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING OUR BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK.
A FEW YEARS AGO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SPENT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS DEL SOURCE IT
WORKERS.
AND THEIR EXISTING WORKERS WERE
FORCED TO TRAIN THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD TAKE THEIR JOBS.
AND IT WAS FOUND OUT THAT THE
CONTRACT COST TAXPAYERS MONEY IN
THE LONG RUN.
HURT EMPLOYMENT GOT RID OF
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND COST
TAXPAYERS THIS IS A MEASURE
WHICH TIME IS DO.
MORE POORLY GHOST ELECTORATE ASK
THEM TO WEIGH IN AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THEY WERE ESCORTED MISTER JONES
SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACA FOURTEEN BY OUR
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO -- AS SOMEONE WHO'S DONE.
PROBABLY SEVERAL HUNDRED
CONTRACTS THE PUBLIC SECTOR I
KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT IT'S LIKE.
FOR A LOW BALLED BITTER TO COME
IN.
PROMISE THE WORLD TO A
GOVERNMENT ENTITY.
AND THEN IN THE END WE SPEND
MORE WITH A WORD THAT WOULD JUST
TWO WORDS CALL CHANGE ORDERS WE
DON'T ALWAYS DO THE BEST AT
CONTRACTING.
I DON'T ALWAYS DO THE BEST A
DOING THE ORIGINAL CONTRACT.
WHAT HAPPENS IS AFTER THE
CONTRACT GOES OVER AND OVER YOU
DO A CHANGE ORDER?
THAT CHANGE ORDER INCREASES THE
AMOUNT OF THE ORIGINAL -- BID
AND BEFORE LONG YOUR PLANE TWICE
AS MUCH SOMETIMES THREE TIMES
MORE.
THEN THE PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEE.
AND MOST IMPORTANT YOU GET LESS
WORK THAN YOU DID BEFORE.
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES BY RULE ALMOST
ALWAYS NOT ONLY HAVE PRIDE IN
WHAT THEY DO THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY DO THE BEST JOB THAT
MONEY CAN BUY.
YOU WANT SOMEONE THAT THEY HAS A
VESTED INTEREST IN DOING THE
WORK ESPECIALLY TO UC'S.
UC'S AS WE ALL KNOW.
AS WE ALL KNOW HAVE NOT BEEN
VERY COOPERATIVE WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE THIS BILL.
HELPS PROTECT NOT ONLY THE
TAXPAYERS.
BUT IT ALSO GIVES BODY THE
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT MONIES ARE
SPENT APPROPRIATELY.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
SAID.
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE TWELVE
YEAR TERMS.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT RUNNING
FOR OFFICE EVERY TWO YEARS.
THEY'RE IN FOR TWELVE YEARS AND
TO GET ANOTHER TWELVE YEARS IN
PART ALMOST A QUARTER OF A
CENTURY.
WHICH MEANS THEY IGNORE US MOST
OF THE TIME THIS BILL ACTUALLY
HAS A LOOK AT HOW THEY SPEND
TAXPAYERS MONEY AND ACTUALLY HAS
SOME INPUT.
SOME INPUT INTO IT ONE DAY I
WOULD LOVE TO RUN A BILL. TO
SHORTEN THOSE TERMS OR TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THE MORE.
CONSTITUTIONALLY AVAILABLE NOT
ONLY TO THE PUBLIC.
BUT TO THIS BODY.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I WORKED FOR YOU SEE FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS.
THAT'S THE TIME I SPENT AT LARGE
SLAB WHERE YOU SEE WAS THE OUR
CONTRACTOR TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND RAN LAWRENCE LAP.
IN MY FIRST FIFTEEN YEARS
EVERYBODY ON CAMPUS ONCE IN A
PLOY E..
UNLESS YOU'RE COMING IN AND
SELECT TRICIA AND OR SOMETHING
TO DO A JOB THAT TOOK A DAY OR
TWO THEN.
ALONG AROUND NINETY IN THE EARLY
NINETIES.
ARE THEY MADE THE CAFETERIA
WORKERS [inaudible]
CONTRACT WORKERS.
SO PEOPLE WHO WERE GETTING A
PENSION.
PEOPLE WHO WERE GETTING A DECENT
WAGE NOW WORK FOR CONTRACTORS.
WHEN THE CONTRACTOR CAME IN
MAYBE THEY TO HIRE THEM MAYBE
THEY WON'T?
AND THEN IN ANOTHER FIVE YEARS
ANOTHER CONTRACTOR WHO MIGHT
HIRE YOU MIGHT NOT.
BUT NO JOB SECURITY [inaudible]
NO PENSION.
WHAT WAS UC DOING?
WE HEARD YOU SHE SAY.
AT OUR HEARING AND
APPROPRIATIONS -- WE JUST DO
THIS BECAUSE IT'S NECESSARY.
THAT'S NOT TRUE THEY'RE DOING IT
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO CUT COSTS
AND THEY WANT TO CUT COSTS.
BY GIVING WORKERS LESS SECURITY.
LAST PENSIONS.
BASICALLY ABUSING THE SYSTEM.
IF A PERSON CAN DO THE JOB AND
DOES THE JOB YEAR AFTER YEAR
THEY OUGHT TO BE AN EMPLOYEE WE
OUGHT NOT TO ALLOW YOU SEE.
YOUR VIEWS ITS WORKERS THANK YOU.
I GET A COURT MISTER MEDINA
KERRIGAN S. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AYE RISES AS
CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND IS A PROUD GRADUATE OF UC
RIVERSIDE.
IN SUPPORT OF A CA.
FOURTEEN DURING MY TIME AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
AND THE HORRIBLE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I'VE FOUGHT THEN.
AGAINST OUTSOURCING WHETHER IT
WAS LIBRARIANS.
OR BUS DRIVERS OR MAINTENANCE
WORKERS.
BECAUSE I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES THAT
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
EMPLOYED WHETHER IT BE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE THE SAME
WHEN I WAS A TRUSTEE.
AT RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND THE EFFORT WAS MADE TO TRY
TO PRIVATIZE THE BOOKSTORE.
AND OF TAKE OFF THE WORKERS IN
THAT IN THE BOOKSTORE AND MAKE
THEM -- NON PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
THAT EMPLOYEES SHOW THAT THEY DO
A BETTER JOB WHEN THEY ARE ABLE
TO WORK FOR THE INSTITUTION
WHICH THEY TAKE PRIDE IN.
AND AS I'VE FOUGHT AGAINST
CUTTING LIBRARIANS AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER BECAUSE OF BUDGET --
RESTRICTIONS ARE TRYING TO CUT
BUDGET.
I KNOW THAT THAT IS NOT THE WAY
TO DO IT.
THAT LOOKING AT THE LOWEST PAID
WORKERS IS NOT THE PLACE TO CUT
MANY I AM A PROUD SUPPORTER.
OF UC EVERY YEAR I FIGHT. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE INCREASE OUR
FUNDING OF UC BUT I AM VERY
HAPPY AND PROUD TO SUPPORT ACA
FOURTEEN IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
THANKYOU MISTER MEDINA MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI.
WILL VOTE FOR THIS A CA.
BUT I WANT TO RAISE.
SOME CONCERNS THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL KEEP IN MIND.
YOU KNOW I'M VOTING FOR THIS
BECAUSE I SUPPORT WORKERS.
ESPECIALLY MAKING SURE THAT
[inaudible]
ARE -- WORKERS ON THE LOW END OF
THE PAY SCALE OR NOT HAVING
THEIR JOBS CONTRACTED OUT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT A FORGET A FEEL GOD IN
SUPPORTING OUR WORKERS.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE WILLING
TO PAY FOR IT.
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR.
AS A MEMBER OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IN EDUCATION
FUNDING I SUPPORTED THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S REQUEST
FOR NINETY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING FUNDING.
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT.
ACCORDING TO THE FLOOR ANNOUNCES.
THIS MEASURE IF PASSED BY THE
VOTERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MAY RESULT IN ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES.
POSSIBLY IN EXCESS OF A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
SO AGAIN.
YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA IS. ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS THAT WE HAVE GOING FOR US
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
THE BEST PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IF NOT IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AND I'M GONNA CONTINUE THE
CHAMPION THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO SUPPORT
THE WORKERS LET'S SUPPORT THE
WORKERS BY INCREASING FUNDING.
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE BEST
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
MR BELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON A
MEMBERS -- LIKE OUR FRIEND FROM
THE SOUTH BAY OF LOS ANGELES I
RISE AND CAUTIOUS SUPPORT.
OF FLOOD OF THIS A CA.
I I DO BELIEVE THAT CONTRACTING
OUT.
I AND ITS IMPACT ON WAGES AND
BENEFITS AS A REAL ISSUE FOR
WORKERS AND I COMMEND THE MEMBER
FROM -- SAN DIEGO FOR WORKING SO
HARD ON ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT I I DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS -- WE JUST HEARD THE
ESTIMATE OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- THAT THIS
COULD COST THE UC ACTUALLY HAS
THAT NUMBER UP AROUND A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO MILLION WHAT
EVER THE COST MAY BE WE HAVE.
TO CAREFULLY CONSIDER THAT COST.
PARTICULARLY AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAVE ADDED AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
INCREASING ENROLLMENT WELL THIS
IS A REAL ISSUE.
TOO AND I TAKE THE POINT THAT.
AS A MATTER OF FLYING MALADY
THIS CAN ONLY BE CHANGED A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT BUT
THAT'S NOT EXACTLY THE CASE WE
CAN ALSO CHANGE THIS BY USING
THE POWER OF THE PURSE THAT WE
HAVE.
JUST AS WE HAVE WITH UNIVERSITY
AND ROLL MEANT -- WE'VE CHANGED
THE DYNAMIC ON THAT AND WE COULD
WORK HARDER TO CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS FOR
THE BUDGET PROCESS WHICH I THINK
IS FAVORABLE MORE FAVORABLE TO
DOING SOMETHING THAT IS RIGID
AND INFLEXIBLE ONCE IT IS PUT
INTO CONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
WE KNOW HOW BALLOT MEASURES ARE.
WE WE WITH OUR OWN LEGISLATION
FREQUENTLY COME BACK TO CLEAN UP
THAT LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO DO THAT WITH A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
I'M I'M VOTING FOR THIS TODAY I
AM HOPING THAT COOLER HEADS WILL
PREVAIL AND THAT THERE CAN BE A
NEGOTIATED RESOLUTION TO THIS SO
THAT IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE CALM.
A CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT --
BUT FOR TODAY I'M AN AYE VOTE.
THING WAS BLOW SENIOR ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ACA.
MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WANT TO REMIND THIS BODY OF A
FEW THINGS FIRST OF ALL -- THIS
IS A CONSTITUTIONAL MA'AM IT'S
GOING TO BE PUT TO VOTERS IF WE
PASS IT THROUGH FOR THE VOTERS
TO DECIDE.
AND FOR THE VOTERS I THINK TO
HAVE AN HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOW MUCH WE'RE INVESTING OR NOT
INVESTING IN YOU SEE I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD DISCUSSION TO HAVE.
IN A GOOD US.
QUESTION TO PUT TO OUR VOTERS.
ALSO RIO ONE REMIND FOLKS THAT
THIS BILL THIS IS BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD AS A BILL -- I THINK AYE
JOCKEYED IT FOR THREE THREE
TIMES ON THIS FLOOR.
GOT TO THE GOVERNOR AND YOU SEE
INSISTS THAT WE CAN'T IN FACT
MAKE THEM DO THIS.
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT.
THEY CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT.
AND I KNOW THOSE OF YOU OF WORK
THROUGH BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS WITH
YOU SEE OF HER THAT AS WELL.
SO WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO TELL
US THAT THEY CANNOT.
BE FORCED TO PROTECT THEIR
LOWEST WAGE WORKERS THEY
CONTINUE TO PAY THEIR HIGHEST
WAGE WORKERS MORE.
ADMINISTRATORS.
I DON'T LIKE HAVING TO DO A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT FOR
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS SO OBVIOUS.
WE SHOULD JUST BE.
FIGURING OUT TOGETHER.
HOW TO PAY FOR THESE -- WORKERS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THE
POSITION WE'RE IN AND CONTINUE
TO BE AN BECAUSE THE WAY THE
CONSTITUTION IS WRITTEN.
SO IF YOU SEE TRULY IS A THOMAS
I KNOW THE CONSTITUTION IS THERE
TO PROTECT.
THOSE WHO ARE THE LEAST AMONG US.
SO PERHAPS IT IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE. TO GIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS TO
THE LEAST.
PAID WORKERS THE WORKERS WHO DO
THE REAL WORK ON UC CAMPUS WHO
WILL NEVER HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATING
POWER.
IN THIS BUILDING OR IN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS WITH YOU SEE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK TODAY.
THAT WE PASS THIS FORD.
THAT WE DO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
ARE YOU SEE THAT WE HAVE REAL
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW MUCH THAT
IS.
BUT WE LET THE VOTERS DECIDE
WHETHER THEY'RE NOT THEY THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO PROTECT
UC WORKERS.
UP AND DOWN THE SPECTRUM
INCLUDING THOSE WERE PAID THE
LEAST.
AND THOSE ARE CONTRACTED OUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MRS OLSEN WITH THAT
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
THIS IS A TWO THIRDS
[inaudible]
MEN AND ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
ABOUT.
TAKES
[inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT.
AYE AYES [inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR THOSE.
TWELVE THE ACA PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BOUNCE
BACK TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE WE HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
UP ON SENATE THIRD READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FORTY DOCTOR RECOMMEND THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
FORTY SB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORPORATE WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EIGHT MEN
[inaudible]
HE WAS. EIGHT SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
IS AN AGRICULTURAL BILL BACK
HERE FOR CHAPTER IN AMENDMENTS I
ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AYMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION MADE WITHOUT
OBJECTION OR WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE MEMBERS ALL THE FAVOR SAY
AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO
PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND AB SAY CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL THREE OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR JONES AND ASHLAND
ESTATES AND TRUSTS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER.
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REIGNING
ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION.
SEVEN I SEVEN OH ZERO THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY FIFTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY JUNE.
TWENTY SIX CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH
FLOOR SESSION.
IS AT NINE AM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
GERMAN TO MEMORY A QUORUM CALL
IS NOT LIFTED.
A QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
AND GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
MR.
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
NOW SO WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
SACRAMENTO POLICE OFFICER.
TARA O'SULLIVAN.
A TWENTY SIX YEAR OLDS
SACRAMENTO POLICE DEPARTMENT
FIRST YEAR TRAINEE.
THE SOUL OF AN WAS TRAGICALLY
GUNNED DOWN BY RESPONDING TO A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DISTURBANCE.
LAST WEEK.
SHE WAS LITERALLY PATIENTLY
HELPING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR.
RETRIEVED HER BELONGINGS WHEN
SHE WAS AMBUSHED BY A HIGH
POWERED ASSAULT RIFLE.
TAKEN FROM OUR PLANET FAR TOO
EARLY.
SHE LIVES SHE GREW UP IN THE
EAST BAY WE HEAR FROM HER
REPRESENTATIVE.
AND A FEW MOMENTS -- BUT SHE
LIVES JUST BLOCKS FROM HERE IN
MIDTOWN SACRAMENTO.
SHE LOVES SACRAMENTO LOVED HER
CITY.
SHE LOVED HER NEW CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO GRADUATE FROM
SAC STATE LAST YEAR WITH A
DEGREE IN CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
UPON OUR GRADUATION ARE PRESENT
A SACK STATE ASTOR WHY WOULD YOU.
PURSUE A CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS GRADUATED WITH A
CAREER AND A DEGREE IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT.
SHE SAID THAT SHE WANTED TO KNOW
EVERYBODY IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
UNDERSTANDING PEOPLE WOULD
BETTER HELP HER DO THE JOB WHICH
SHE WAS ABOUT TO BEGIN.
SHE WAS.
AND ONE OF THE FIRST MEMBERS OF
SACKS STATES LAW ENFORCEMENT
CANDIDATES SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
A NEW PROGRAM HERE AT SAC STATE
HELPING ASSIST LOCAL AND STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT RECRUITING
PERSONNEL WHO LOOK LIKE IN MERE
THE COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS THE FUTURE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HER FAMILY.
AND HER FRIENDS WILL REMEMBER
HER WITH HER BIG HEART.
STRONG MINDS A GREAT PERSONALITY
AND A CONTAGIOUS SMILE.
OFFICER O'SULLIVAN WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED BY HER FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
AND BY THE COMMUNITY WHICH SHE
SERVED SHE SIR PROBABLY AS A
HERO.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY MISTER
COOPER YOUR ALSO RECOGNIZE ON
THIS IS GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS EVERY
DAY THOUSANDS OF MEN AND WOMEN
RESTORE LIVES. FOR THE SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF OUR CITIZENS
SIRI.
THE USE OF PRIDE AND SELFISHNESS
ALSO SOLD ONLY TRUE EXAMPLE OF
THAT.
SHE EMBODIED WORLDLY HONOR AND
INTEGRITY.
AT TWENTY SIX YEARS OF AGE
AUSTRAL SULLIVAN WITH THE YOUNG
STAR ON THE RISE WITHIN THE
SACRAMENTO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
TWENTY SECOND WAS THE UNIVERSITY
TERROR WAS THE FIRST OF FOUR
STUDENTS AND THE ONLY WOMAN TO
COMPLETE THE UNIVERSITY'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAT IT.
SCHOLARS PROGRAM LAST YEAR I THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET TERRA THE
FIRST EVER ELLIE CS GRADUATION.
REMEMBER HOW SHE CARRIED HERSELF
CHOOSE A GO GETTER A YOUNG WOMAN
PLACE FOR LEADERSHIP THE
SUCCESSFUL CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SHE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE SO MUCH
SO SHE SACRIFICED HER LIFE FOR
COMMUNITY.
ALSO SULLIVAN SEARCHER STATE IN
OUR COMMUNITY WITH HONOR AND
DISTINCTION.
HER SELFISHNESS ENCOURAGE WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
MY HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES AND
PRAYERS WATER FAMILY AND HER
FRIENDS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN AND THE
MEMORY OF OFFICER TERRA
O'SULLIVAN.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER MR GRAYSON
YOU TWO ARE RECOGNIZED MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO ARISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
OF OFFICER O'SULLIVAN WHO PASSED
AWAY JUNE NINETEENTH IN
SACRAMENTO AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
TWENTY SIX THIS IS ALL OF AN
INNER FAMILY WERE NATIVES OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE IN
DURING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
GRIEF FROM HER LOS.
THIS IS ALL OF AND GREW UP IN
PLEASANT HILL AND ATTENDED
COLLEGE PARK HIGH SCHOOL.
SHE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY WHO SPENT MUCH OF HER
TIME WORKING WITH LOCAL YOUTH
SOCCER TEAMS.
SHE WENT ON TO ATTEND THE APPLE
VALLEY COLLEGE BEFORE
TRANSFERRING TO SACRAMENTO STATE.
DURING THIS TIME MISSILE SOLOMON
STARTED HER JOURNEY TOWARDS A
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THROUGH THE PLEASANT HILL AND
MARTINEZ POLICE EXPLORE PROGRAMS.
LIKE SO MANY OTHERS WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT MISSILE SULLIVAN IS
DESCRIBED AS A NATURAL LEADER.
ONE WHO WAS AMBITIOUS.
WHO IS VIBRANT?
AND VERY KIND HEARTED FOR
SERVICE ENCOURAGE WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN SHE DISPLAYED
INCREDIBLE HEROISM AND
SACRIFICED HER LIFE TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITY.
AND OUR WILLINGNESS TO PLACE OUR
LIFE ON THE LINE FOR SERVICE OF
OTHERS COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN
WITH ME IN EXPRESSING.
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE A SOUL OF
AN FAMILY AND A JOINING IN
MEMORY OF OFFICERS.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE RISE.
AS WE OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE.
IN HONOR OF OFFICER TERRA
O'SULLIVAN
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTH.
AT NINE AM.
AND THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
--
VOTE CHANGE.
RAMOS SB.
SEVENTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
SENATE BILL SEVENTY EIGHT I IT'S
NOT VOTING